[inaudible]
is it actually happening? Should it be all right ladies. Gentlemen,
flight companion and started Brian couns in route. Brendan shops in the house.
Eddie motherfucking bravo with the new haircut. Yep. I like it dude.
You're going straight up Tom Po as you grow up.
Ponytail on the back of that motherfucker. All right.
If you've never listened to this before,
this is a podcast where we watched the fights and we talk. Shit,
we're day drinking. It's 11:15 AM Eddie Bravo hasn't cracked open one yet.
Here you go. I'm scared. I'm scared.
Especially Post Epstein is a lot of conspiracy. Glen in the circle.
What's the big deal? That's what I've been telling everybody. [inaudible] Tyson.
Mom's a fucking beast and he's about to fight Diego for Hara.
And that is an excellent fight. So if you never heard these before, we're just,
we talked shit while the fights are going on.
We kind of commentate on the fights, but not really. Let's be honest.
It depends. Most of it's not. There's a very good fight. Um,
mayor back tie some off is a fucking killer.
Diego Ferera is a very good fighter too. So this is a,
this is a good fight and they're in Abu Dhabi. So you know,
when you think about a guy like tie some off, who's Muslim,
you gotta think that there's a lot of, lot of pride him fighting there,
but maybe a little bit of extra pressure home field advantage. Right.
So I don't know about home field advantage man.
Cause sometimes guys don't fight well when they're fighting in front of everyone
that they love and care for too much pressure and there's a lot more to worry
about. Did you hear, I forget what journalists is, cage side, but I guess the,
around the cage and the mat, it's hot as fuck. Oh, it's hot dude. No,
but they're saying it's like unheard of hot around there.
So as the rounds getting going, yeah, I think,
I think it could affect some of the fights. Most,
most people in most teams do play better with home field advantage.
It's kind of like, yeah, it's like you have no choice. You can't, you can't,
uh, crumble under the pressure.
It's like there's too many of your loved ones watching. You have no choice.
It's like some people just fold man tie some. I was looking good though.
Just landed a good left leg kick and a good one too. He's,
he's a solid fighter man, but he's one of those guys who's had a hard time.
I think he's had a hard time getting into the u s I think that's,
I think he was denied visas or something like that.
I would imagine a lot of these guys on this car did like Khabib's dad can't get
in, but he's in his corner for this site. Crazy.
What do they think he's going to do?
But the problem is he's got a tie to that guy from Chechnya. Tough. Yeah.
Oh Diego forever. Just cracked him.
Tossed him off as the St Barbara's Brian Callan.
Can we get the fights on this TV too? So Iris, cause I don't have to.
So you have to [inaudible] no, it's on apple TV
and my neck, Bro. You don't know where we're lying. I'm looking right now.
It says there's people watching, but I can't find it. So, but looking,
I'm looking. Are you watching it? Can you see it? I can see it on my thing.
My having
a little bit of an issue with Youtube, ladies and gentlemen. Um,
when you get it to me, uh, get it. Do me a favor. Um, give me a link. Just,
just, uh, tweet it or something and I'll retweet it.
Something, something, something. When I was over there, uh,
when Anderson Silva fought Damien Maya, it was hot as fuck. And it was outdoors.
So you, you were there. That's right. You went to, that was fun. That was
[inaudible] man. We for the UFC we had no choice. Yeah.
And you have to go at all.
Did you have to go to Oregon back then about it though? We were like, damn,
it's going to be honest. We were pumped, but bro,
there were bugs the size of dogs flat
like bugs I'd never saw before. Like I didn't even know existed.
I heard it's cool out there though. I heard it's a great, well,
Dubai is gorgeous and there's so much money.
Henslowe said it's like Las Vegas on steroids. He's hurt, he's hurt.
It's over for era's hurt. Oh really? Hurt. He's really hurt.
He's a smart dude though. He's, he's gonna, he's gonna stay away. Look,
he's popping out just to make sure that, uh,
he knows it's okay that he's, uh,
still still a dangerous fighter, but he's in, he's in real bad.
[inaudible] Baxter's 45 or 55 55 I believe.
I might be wrong, Jamie and find out for us.
I think Tyson, Mt. 50 55 for sure. Lightweight. Yeah. Yeah.
55 Diego though. His Diego fought at 45 before.
[inaudible]
maybe I'm wrong. It's hard to tell man. There's so many fighters in the UFC now.
It's just, it's so difficult to keep tracks on all, dude. How about Nate miles,
but all woo secured the bag. It's happening. Yeah.
Was it November 2nd Madison Square Garden November 2nd.
And they're still working on Colby and smog, but they're not though.
Cause they want to pay. Well they are trust don't they?
They don't want to pay Colby with Colby wants. Oh we cracked them again but did,
but the Dana said that that will be the main event.
They don't want to put a title fight above that. So then so, so there,
there's no way you'd make Kobe, you so Mazda, don't Nate Diaz is the main event.
Is that I'm almost positive Jim. That's,
I mean it's five rounds and Dana said he doesn't want to put a title fight above
that. Well, if that's the case, then I figured it out. They're going to,
we are alive. They changed the fucking way it works now. Okay,
so is it Joe Rogan. Dot Live. Okay.
And Dana's making a belt for just for that. Like the people's champ belt. Oh,
like the streets not, well,
Nate says it's the baddest motherfucker in the game belt. Yeah, that's what,
that's what he's making. You got to say that on TV.
You can't say bad ass motherfucker in the game.
Maybe it's just like the hardcores belt, you know? That's the,
that's the fucking, I'm so happy they made that fight.
I didn't think it was going to happen. Dude. I got,
I didn't think was going to happen when I saw it on my Instagram feed this
morning. I threw my arms up in the air, like somebody got knocked out.
I was like, I want to sell you at the Improv. I was like,
I don't think it's going to happen. Then I was like,
I feel like Nate needs too much. It's just
too much. It's been cases, it's worth money. Well, you know,
Dana said something, you know,
I'd said that I think that that Nate Diaz is one of the biggest superstars in
the game right up there with everybody. Z top five. Yes. And then Nate and Da,
I guess there was some negotiations or something cause Dana refuted. I goes,
well I don't think that Nate Diaz in our longterm plans and Nate fights once
every three years. And I'm like, don't say that.
That could be him playing the game though. Still trying to learn Nate out.
I'm just like, come on Nate. And also let them know that look,
we've got other plans. There's other shit we're doing. I just retweeted that.
Oh, you did? Okay. All right. What is the link? I don't know.
Is it the powerful Jerry Page? Yeah, it's on there,
but it's not that link we have. All right, hold on a second. Young Jane.
Um, I'm just excited, but I want Uzman versus uh,
versus Colby. That's the fight to make. Oh, 100%. That card stack though,
even without loosening Kobe,
I hope they worked that out cause I want to see that. But Mossville Nate,
you can just, I'll just buy that fight. I don't care who it, those two guys,
not only are the two the baddest motherfuckers ever, but they're funny as fuck.
They're both great. They're funny. They're both super necessary. Yeah.
All that shit. Three piece and a soda. I haven't, I named a move,
a transition three piece into such brilliant after Hamp, it's sober. It's,
and I showed it to him to learn this. I got to know that it's, yeah,
he's got to know three piece with the soda. That guy is so good. He's so good.
And so he's so clever. You know,
that's one of the best things to say about Matsuda.
And the thing is people don't necessarily associate him with knockout power for
some reason, but yet the guy knocked out Eve Edwards with a head kick.
He knocked out Darren tail cowboy Serone tell Ben asked grand and put him in
another dimension with a flying knee world record. Fastest knockout. I mean,
it's weird that people don't associate Mazda doll with the knockout artist
because he doesn't have, he doesn't necessarily have the most power,
but he's so good. It's so calculated the way he set up that knee.
Is this the the car? Yes. The Kelvin versa. Dan till's. Interesting.
Derek Lewis Lewis versa, a blog,
knee eve novel of Johnny Walker. Corey Anderson. Boy,
I forget, I forget how to say that guy's name. Blank goal. Have enough even off.
I think it's even even off. He's a scary dude.
He is that kind of scary yet staffed yet in the heart.
So he stabbed in a hurt coriander and Johnny Walker's a good fight. But dude,
Johnny Walker shoulder's still fucked up.
I just sent you that video of him working out. He's mobility's not great,
but he's also, he's throwing punches with only one arm.
He's not in the videos of him working out.
And then there's other videos of him going through strength and conditioning and
you see what he's doing with his left arm. And I'm like, Jesus crisis.
Like he's not lifting any weight with his left arm. Yeah,
hopefully he's all right. How Bout fricking a Kelvin verse till Oh, that's good.
Fight Hill was like, Nah
man, let me just go after these fucking monsters.
Well he legitimately is a middle weight. I mean he,
that guy was killing himself making one 79 creed but y but the coming off the
two losses that he suffered and then you know, obviously the,
he had some issues while in Alabama and Liverpool and wherever Bali or whether
he ruined that hotel.
So he's going through something and then they just give him Frickin,
well I think he asked for Kelvin. I don't care. I'm a fan. I'm a fan too.
Fucking crazy. Both. Both those guys. Oh Kelvin's so good.
I think Kimber's style bender was my favorite. Middleweight fight of all time.
Just rock ties him off Bro. Tyson mops in a little bit of trouble right here
for Harris solid man. He solid. Oh, oh, tie some off. Might be in trouble.
Oh my God. He's winging shots at his face to that right and just barely missed.
Some guy gets starched on the prelims. Do ties him off.
It's in a little trouble here right now. He's laughing and puffing. Flat footed,
huffing and puffing. They said to him 99 degrees in there right now.
That is so ridiculous. Now is this had an outdoor arena? No,
I thought they built it for this. Right? Are they saving money on AC?
What the fuck? The first one? Yeah. This is the first event in the arena.
I believe the AC broke. Someone's going to get hanged. Yeah, someone's dying
so that oil money, they'll fuck around. They're not fucking around. Oh my God.
Is it really 99 degrees in that Saul thing?
He said 99 to dead is so bad to fight at 99 degrees.
You've got to be acclimated to that shit and even then you're still gonna have a
performance hit. You're gonna definitely have a performance hit.
Probably similar to fighting at very high altitude like Mexico City type deal.
They don't look that sweaty though, do they? Well, it's hard to tell. You know?
I mean we're, we're not in there. They look sweaty as fuck you sweat.
It's fuck you thing sweating. But I mean they just fought two rounds.
I mean this was during the second round.
Oh was a big mouse into the left I have for Hara. God,
we haven't done one of these in a long time. It's been a hot second.
When was the last one we did a, I couldn't even tell you. It's been months.
Callen is in his gym shorts right now filming his television show.
But he's on the way.
You think it'd be possible to do team MMA like Americans versus Brazilians Bro
Rush. But like for countries like you take Olympics like the Olympics,
but you do it in the UFC.
You take the best guy at 35 best guy at 45 like the ultimate Russian's about to
run the table except for heavy,
late February you put off everybody could be everybody.
All the lessons are taken over everything. Look at what they're doing in boxing.
It's Russians and black guys rushing and black guys are owning the fight world.
But Russians like the whole light heavyweight division.
I had Andre Ward on the other day, he's brilliant. He is every champion,
all these two contenders, like 78% of them are rushing. It's crazy.
There's so many killer Russians when we think about the champs and now,
I mean it's either, well, shit, it's either Russian or black, right?
Except for [inaudible]. The winning team gets $1 billion.
I did get to for hair. I just cracked it and I hand tied some ops in trouble.
Man. He's bleeding too. He's bleeding out of his nose called the UFC Olympics.
That'd be pretty bad ass dude. If you got pseudo at a what? Oh no,
he didn't, he wasn't born in Mexico. What did you say?
Heat index is one 23 in there. Dominic Cruz, which is quoted as saying,
I'm cooking like a biscuit in here.
The heat index is one 23 so it feels like 120 it's not gonna be good for
performance. That's ridiculous. Imagine the third,
fourth round for could be even dusted. Ooh, dude, that's nice. Kiss.
I feel like advantage.
The court K I'm no really training in Florida. I don't think any,
how does fudge,
well, they're in the air conditioned environment. They don't trade outside.
I mean he's not training too in his,
I mean maybe the new ward that Jim in New Orleans had no AC. Right.
Maybe advantage poor yet. Yeah, maybe. I mean, I wouldn't bank on it though.
I think Beverly is going to be compromised. The fact that it's that hot.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna text Dominick just cause I can see what's going on.
How do they know that that should happen? Well, you got,
you got Joshua Verse Ruiz in Saudi Arabia and they're building just a fucking
arena for it. Just for that one fight.
Sure. Trying to find,
they built this arena just for this fight. No, for Joshua Ruiz and December.
I'm just, I'm in the middle of texting because it,
this is only the second event in this one though. Maybe fuck the pope. Pour.
Pour. Yay. Finally your title shot. Here you go. When this one though,
we're coming back to New Orleans, I'd imagine.
All right. I just sent him a text.
He might respond in between rounds if he has a time.
[inaudible] a little Dominic Cruz.
Shout out to Dominick Cruz right hand to the back of the head for hair.
It looks better and you got to think for Hara is trained in Brazil, right?
Is he in Brazil right now? Training and he's from Brazil. I know,
I don't know screening,
but Brazil obviously gets very hot and a lot of gyms in Brazil are open air
gyms,
but he looks to me better like physically the way he's moving and Tyson him off.
Looks like he's just trying to get his, his wind back.
And he had a really good first round,
so he might have emptied out a little bit in that first round.
Who I like for heroin here.
If I was walking in right now and somebody wanted to bet cash for Harris looking
good. He's looking real good man. He's, Oh look at that man.
So He's, he's fighting at a real good pace. Oh, don't do that. Don't do that.
Ooh Elbow. Ooh, right hand. Damn. You know what?
I've been watching a lot lately on youtube. I've been watching left way.
You know what that is? No,
that set a Moitai with no gloves and headbutts
Jesus Christ. Yeah, it's crazy.
There's this Guy David Ledoux and he's like the king of lifeway and he's a
friends with Robin black like Robyn Blackston breakdowns of his stuff and Robin
has done some commentary for left way wild shit to watch man. Where did,
where are they do a man not here, I think. I don't know where he lives.
You watch that bare knuckle boxing.
SAS changed my opinion on whether or not MMA should be bear now. Fellows.
I knew you'd come around huts. I knew you'd come rounds.
The cuts are too much clear.
Chris leaving his whole face is like a an ax murderer.
You got hit in the head with patch. You see it's a big foot for skin saga. Yeah.
I don't like that. I don't like that makes me sad.
That's a big foot on the see it seems like, uh,
what's, what's the name of the show?
The event did not go fighting championship, B. K, f.
C it just seems like it's blowing up. Right. It is blown up.
I mean people are Naji fighting Artem low.
Bob got people excited about you see the numbers though. What kind of,
what kind of blown up ups all relative.
What's the numbers bringing that shit up. Jamie is, it's not great.
He said over 200 something thousand but it came out it was like 11,000 or
something so it wasn't crazy.
Like the pay per view numbers to Diego for heroin is putting it on Tice him off.
I'm Arabic Tyson monks in real trouble right now.
He just got hit with a big right hand and he's not offering any offense right
now. He's just trying to gather his shit and just moving away.
Like even when he's throwing punches it's like they're not dangerous.
So you like right here. Reminds me of Tony Ferguson here. Yup.
This just some chop. Just stocking him down or just do still numbers on Tony.
Tony Ferguson has changed the game in terms of like a guy who has the ability to
put it on you and doesn't get tired. He is at the top of the fucking list.
I've never seen anybody like him that you know when he's going to do the next
project, he's going to open up a 10th planet and big bear.
He wants to live in big bear. I like it. He's good.
That's got us some impact on,
it says just 18,000 people downloaded it.
They said 200,000 but then there's ways to count them. Shutters reporting.
Maltsters a pretty solid source. Yeah, he's legit. Legit journalists.
18,000 that's not a lot.
18,000 I would say I was a no, that that Logan Paul Ksi too.
That's going to be under zone will get fucking 7 million or some shit like that.
Joe Saunders is on the undercard of that, which is so ridiculous. What?
What? What? Billy Joe Saunders is fighting on the undercard of Logan.
Paul's one of the top 20 fighters on the planet earth. I would say kickboxing.
No boxing. Oh, it's to youtube as you fought before. Wow.
Well now it's a different game, isn't it?
I was on board when they were just fighting each other.
Billy Joe Saunders is a fucking, he's an artist. Heavyweight. No,
Billy Joe is a middleweight right? No, he, yeah, he could probably,
I'd love to see him, but against Cornell,
I think you'd give Canelo some Fritz my favorites is everybody's Tyson fury.
His best friend. Yeah, he's hilarious.
They pope and match and Ferrari's all the time. They're great.
He fights like them too in a lot of ways. They're very mobile.
He's a bad ass man. Very Mobile. Um, wow. I bet it's embarrassing.
That's a better, oh, another head kit, bro.
T entice him off is not offering anything dangerous in return.
I think he's like severely compromised right now. Cracked again.
Who are the judges? Um, that's a good question. Adelaide,
Adelaide bird. See peoples. Who else? Uh,
I don't know who's like, who do you get excited about for judges?
Judge Adelaide. Burt. Cause I know it's gonna be chaos. Yeah, I see.
You're really, you Doug Crosby like for real. Who is?
Um, oh look at that. That's the end of the house. There's no way.
You don't tell him there's no one that fight another country.
You don't know what the fuck's going to happen. Absolutely man.
They can't do it would be an embarrassment for them if they gave that to Tyson.
You don't give [inaudible] face got beat up. She loses early in the fight.
Tyson mom cracked him. Why are they showing just his highlight? Hey,
that could sway judges. Why are they showing justice at the end of the fight?
That's the end. The fight is the first round.
You see Tice them off coming onto you. They're just showing, okay.
They showed that. No, but then as the fight wears on,
then you see Diego come on strong. Listen, I work in that fucking production.
They showed the first round and then second,
the first round was all tie some off,
but then the second and third they see now they're showing for heroin.
Put your draw him ten eight that first SRE. Do you look at this crack?
It's fair. It was a beast, man. Look at the numbers though. Come on.
Even round one. The numbers are crazy. Well,
the thing is like Tyson off hit him with big shots and round one.
That's terrible for Tyson off because Tyson off has not fought in the UFC in
quite awhile. And for him to come back to the UFC, he,
Jamie on the other screen, can you pull up Diego for heroes a record?
He's a fucking good fighter, man. He's a good fighter. But again,
the endurance thing, nobody's like Tony.
I mean literally like he's like a superhuman.
I've never seen anybody that can sustain an attack like Ferguson.
No one. So what does he got here? You lost a Dustin. He lost a Banio.
[inaudible] you got Dustin Kao. Dustin's a monster,
but he beat a Olivier. Obama merciay.
He beat Reus Dom Kabulov. Those are good fighters, man. Really good.
Yeah, he's a, he's the best father fucker. If he, if he fucking loses. Oh,
that he won. He Won. Maribel went down.
And what did he thought he was gonna win and no, no,
he didn't think he's going to win. I think that she's praying. Yeah,
I think he's praying and then he kind of got to pray in front of those people.
You never know. Yeah, no fucking way, dude. If he won that fight,
it would've been a horrible travesty of justice.
How do you remember Alessio Sakara versus Tallis
latest? No. Don't you don't remember that one? No. What happened? That one,
uh, Sakara got the decision but um,
Talis latest took them down over and over. Never really got hit standing and uh,
took his back like two or three times and Sacara escaped all the back attempts
and then got back to his feet.
So the replays were all Sakara his escapes back escapes.
Where was it? Guess who won was a car? Yeah. Really?
Cause the replays influenced the judges, man. You think so? I know. So dude,
I was in the truck doing not a hell.
Wow. What did you say? Hey,
how come you guys aren't showing the replays of the take downs in the back
control?
I don't remember what happened. Watch that fight.
And then you'll see at the end all the replays are Sacara escaping back control.
And he won. Was this back in the day? When was this?
This was probably about 12 years ago. Oh Wow. Yeah.
They don't know what the fuck they was going to throw in chicken bones to
decide. Watch that fight and then tell me who won, who won it on? No. Wow.
It's amazing that you brought that up. That's a crazy fight.
I'll never forget that one. That's how I know that sticks in my brain.
Like those replays. That's, that's why I thought I'll replay,
cause the judges are sitting there going, oh my God, what do I do? What do I do?
So they look at the replays and if the replays are showing one guy is getting
the better, the other guy, then they go, okay, if they in the truck,
they think he's winning. So then okay, he's winning.
You know what's crazy is that that's what happens. Nothing.
Nothing really significant has changed in terms of like the,
the w who judges fights.
It's like basically the same kind of people. The same people. You don't,
you're not seeing, look you, Ricardo Almeda as a judge in New York,
which is a great thing, but you're not seeing a lot of that.
You're not seeing a lot of fights. Ricardo made a type job. Yes, yes.
Either form of fighters or martial arts experts.
Like if you say that you want to be a judge, I w I want to see you.
Show me how you apply. Doris chokes.
Show me what's different between the Anaconda choke and the dark chokes.
Show me when you know, show me how, how, how do you do a 10 finger guillotine?
Show me. Show me. If you don't know what that is.
If you don't know how to do it,
how are you going to know whether or not someone's in danger,
whether in the middle of a fight.
I'd also show him fights like the one you were talking about with Sakara and
ladies and be like, how do you score this kind of thing to me.
You guys are talking,
you guys are talking all sorts of fucking common sense dude. What it's about.
Just hit me back. Right? Dominick Cruz. Well, I don't want to say that,
but he says so fucking hot. Part of what he said, I will not repeat. Yeah,
he says fucking hot. You can't say fuck that fee. I can say that.
I can't say what he say. I'll show you. He wants to do it. Yes sir. A racist?
No, no, no. Dominic's not racist at all. No.
Okay. Yeah, yeah. Show that to Brendan.
But tell him to shut the fuck up about it on your pod.
I'm a, we should all go to New York.
I'm not doing a show in New York because I'm going to do Madison Square Garden
afterwards. I'm going to do with a far afterward. What show is that?
I'm going to do Madison Square Garden in 2020.
So with Chappelle? No, by myself.
You're doing Madison Square Garden. Stand up style. You're somebody.
You've done it before though, Joe? No, not the big one, right?
I did the little arena before. Wait a minute by yourself. Jim Does big,
big guys places. It's fun. So what were you going to say Joe Though?
That's November 2nd. So you're looking to do one before then? Um, yeah,
I'm not doing a show on November 2nd you know, we should,
we should do a podcast in New York. How about we all fly down in New York.
I'll get you guys seats ringside and the night before we just do a talk and shit
podcast. Free flight card. A pregame wait,
there's going to be a UFC and then you're going to do Madison Square Garden. No,
no, no. I'm doing Madison Square Garden a couple months later.
So you're not talking about that show? No,
quite about actually watch a few months later.
So it's like November is when the UFC is there.
I'm not doing a show there until 2020. What show is a Madison Square Garden?
That's the big one. That's Nate Diaz. Mazda dog. That's November. Yeah,
November six. Garren til November 2nd. Calvin gas alum.
How about if we did that? We did a, uh, like a fight companion preview.
Get drunk talk shit. My hotel room on November 2nd.
I'm free that weekend. Oh, I mean if you want to do it, we could do it. Hold.
That'd be so much fun.
This fight style bender style bender versus Robert Whittaker. Oh my goodness.
That's going to be a big fight. I can't wait for that fight. I'm in town too.
And so only weekend. I'm not on the road. Ooh, look at us dude. I'm,
I'm really excited about this. Whitaker versus style benders.
My big fight for the year. I think that's my big fight. I can't wait for that.
Not Sorry. Adam Green Tree. Not Big enough for get me to fly to Australia.
They try to get me to fly over there for this one too. I'm like, hmm.
Rather be here rather be here folks.
But style bender versus Whitaker's to fight mass fight. That's the fight.
Just so they're both in their prime dude. Then. How about uh, Kosta,
now he's ranked what? He's two now. I think he's right there, man.
He's so scary. They're all scared. He ate everything. John Jones,
is that what you're thinking? No, he's nothing. Weight class. What?
He's easy to coast a style bender. But you know, they want a,
they want coaster to move up. California does. California is like, Hey man,
you're cutting too much fucking weight.
California is not going to eliminating those only fought once in California
though. So if California says he miss, wait, no, he made weight. But,
and here's the thing that they said.
They say you can't gain more than 15 pounds. What does that say?
56 seating capacity.
40,000,
40,000 tickets already sold in Australia for Whitaker versus out of Sanya.
Holy Shit. Oh my goodness.
October 6th in the month of [inaudible] Marvel Stadium.
I like how Marvel Comic Stadium do the underwriting Ronda Rousey home holds the
record. Does it, did they just said that? Oh Wow.
Oh Wow. That was the whole state record for MMA in Australia saying,
I remember being there. That was crazy. And you think Rhonda let her come back?
Nope. No, I don't think she wants to. I think Rhonda is a strong woman.
You know, she decides she's done. She's done. She's going to move on.
I don't think she wanted to, you know, to keep doing it. I just think,
you know,
making money off when she came back and fought Amanda and then Amanda knocked
her out, um, that must have like really fucked her up, Matt mentally.
But like now looking back like Amanda's the, she fucked up Cyborg.
Like she would've fucked up anybody. So I'm thinking that Rhonda is,
feels a little bit better about that. Amanda fight, right?
Maybe she got knocked out by Holly before that though.
And they got starched by Amanda. Yeah.
But then Amanda just knocked out Holly with a fucking still,
even today they weren't competitive. Even today. Still,
even today if the fights on the ground, you got to give it to Rhonda.
Rhonda, I don't feel I'm better than you. I don't know about that with Amanda
[inaudible] Jujitsu. Yeah. Yeah.
But men is the owned everybody on the ground with arm bars,
but she's had a very singular attack.
Armbars it was all armed bars and she was at fighting great competitions saying
if she just focused on her judo and, and her arm bars and, and,
and didn't try to be a striker, um, you think she'd be like, it could beep now.
I think if she went to American top teams, you lose a couple. Everyone loses.
You just, you lose, you come back, everyone loses and they come back. You know,
I think Rhonda would still be in the mix 100%.
She would have to separate and move to a real camp.
She would have to train with real trainers, like a real group of killers,
grappling trainers, wrestling trainers,
make sure she's got the best barring partners and more importantly coach a real
mind. A real like, like fuck Ross for us.
The hobby like selling like that or you know Mike Brown or you know Duke Roufus.
Someone top of the food chain person. Matt, Matt Hume, right.
A top of the food chain coach. Why would she just gonna break? She wouldn't,
that's why she's killing it and she wants to Travis.
Oh this fucking back. This was crazy shit watching Steve Page just knock out DC.
It was crazy dude.
Those Kush blades on now dude steeping.
How much money is Ronda make it in the WWE millions.
Millions of money making million, million more money than she's ever met. No,
she, she's getting paid to pretend.
So why the fuck would you risk all that and go back to UFC?
What do you think about king the last,
cause you think he's going to stick with it? You see
him? He's good. It's, I mean, he is on the flip down and shit.
He put that mask on and with the Mexican Lucci I leave it a fucking crew dude.
He could be huge. Instead, he loves you. He could be huge into,
he's doing flips and shit and counts the people's legs and throwing Nacho is
Kinda fucked up back. How can he do all that Shit [inaudible] back? Oh he does.
Or does he have a fucked up? You know, he just over it and like,
I'm gonna go put this mask on and get paid not to get punched in the face.
A big difference between a flip that you orchestrate yourself versus someone
fucking picking you on the claim and you're on the ground and the right training
and you know,
wrestling with how crazy is it that people are into fake fighting fucking they
love it. They love, they're passionate about it too. And if you talk shit about,
they come at you in a row. Trust me. I know. Trust me. I know.
But look, Tony Hinchcliffe, who I love to death, that fucking kid lives for it.
He lives for fake friends. Billy Corgan from smashing punk. People love.
It's one of the organizations. Yeah. Billy loves one. Yeah.
They might as well make movies and TV shows while they're at it now they want to
see it live. They want to see like a live play. It's like a live wild,
crazy play. I respect it. Look, it's like they, they grind, they grind.
It's hard. It falls into other shit like video games, cartoons, comic books,
nerd culture.
It's like stuff that you enjoyed when you were a kid and these guys embrace it
deep into adulthood. It's fun for them. I get it. I don't mind it. They always,
they always like compare it to Guac. Jones. They do make movies.
I don't know if you knew that. That's a no WWE movie.
Hold on a second. Either WWE movies,
they make movies. No, these are wrestlers are starring in movies. No. Look,
WWE studio. There's whole shit. I didn't know that. Oh Damn.
They are making movies. Oh yeah. Oh Wow. Okay.
Has anybody heard of any of these movies? Hey, watch your mouth. No Man.
I've heard of the marine. I've heard of them. Or, oh,
fighting with family with the rock. I heard decent. How dare you.
Okay. Okay. How dare you jingle all the way to sandals. Little hell suck this.
Change this right now. I don't want to look at this.
Get that off the air to the hose. Hey Dude. Hey real quick though.
Those were terrible. They might've been
go to her. All you gotta do. If I come and watch one of those movies
[inaudible]
that and all the Tyler Perry's movies will please a woman. Yeah,
Jesus Christ. He's done like 18 of those. Oh, we get it. We get it.
[inaudible] a woman. Was he dressed like a woman in real life?
You'd have to ask him a gun to the head.
Yeah.
Got into the head one time. His dog pops at least one time. If I had a bet,
everything closed off on his own. Is He ever put pumps off?
Does he have a size
14 pump? It is from, yeah, I listen. You gotta respect,
respect transgenders 1000% you know what I mean? You got to,
but I think like after 16 like after 60 stop,
if you keep wearing makeup and wigs at 60
you should about for ladies like Christie Brinkley's over 60 hey listen,
but still wearing makeup. But if your health, Cindy Crawford,
if you're a transgender and you're over 60 you should probably dress like old
ladies. Right? And with the,
with the gray wig [inaudible] there's different ladies like look,
Christie Brinkley of, you've seen what she looks like now.
I think she's 64 she's still Huston. Stunning. Huh?
No filter. Not long legs. No. No. Little bit earlier. Hurley,
Elizabeth Hurley's Instagram has goddamned hilarious.
It is all her and her underwear. Every picture, all the shape. 85 years old.
[inaudible] picture.
She's only in eight 52 she's like 54 or 55 that would have been Clinton
[inaudible] picture. Allegedly.
Every picture of her is her and her underwear and her Instagram.
She's so bad looking. Good Dude. Look good.
[inaudible] filter she does is eat.
Go to the gym and take pictures in her underwear. I think that's all she does.
She's earned it. Yeah, man. Look,
she's letting everybody know like while she's still got this body,
she's putting that motherfucker front and center all this shit.
She's 85 years old.
85 for 50 54 Christie Brinkley's 65 God damn sick to,
how does she do it? Early 54 yes, dude. She's hot as fuck.
I think that if you saw her to club,
you think that's a 35 year old smoking shit. Look at that smoke show.
That's a serious, no, that's a competition. Janie,
how dare you introduce the songs. The first picture without a filter.
I'm just clicking. No, show me the full screen her. Yes dude.
She's hot as fuck her in 1998 no, no, no, no. Sorry. Last week.
Turner Pool Dude.
When you got that kind of Elizabeth Hurley cash the pig picture right there with
her in the Bikini on the floaty thing on the, on the pink Flamingo.
Every bitch pink hot as fuck. Lunar body man. She keeps it. Tone does.
She has a like a 30 year old son. She has kids. Imagine being her son,
her kids 50 she let us in a new world.
We live in a new world,
a woman like her with massive amounts of resources and she can go to all the
best doctors, hormone replacement, all the best. Like, look, look at that.
That's her and her daughter. Dude, she's hot as fuck. She's 65 years old.
Look at her. Come on son. Daughter looking like ugly friend.
Your mom's hot kid up. [inaudible] though. Yeah.
If you do see any ash ash, Elizabeth Hurley has ashots.
Elizabeth Hurley's as hard for me to believe.
I think at 50 your ass guys can do it. Guys can do it though.
Guys have different kinds of assets. They've longer asses. Hips are narrow,
holds the butt. You can get ass jobs these
days. You can get the
troubles out there thinking about, look, no guys like ass implants. No guys, no,
no, no god, no, no guys. Well, here's the thing.
Girls are starting to develop ass cancer.
They're starting to develop cancer in the same areas were women where some women
are getting breast cancer from implants. It's not always to getting asked. Yes,
sir. Yes, but she cancer. But from the implants,
are they doing the Brazilian both, which is fat. Let me answer.
It's a reaction to the implants.
Your body doesn't want foreign substances in its body.
If you put something in your body, a piece of plastic,
and then your body like has to go, why is this here? What the fuck is this?
And your body starts to fight it and reject it and then you develop scar tissue
around it. That's why a lot of older ladies that got boob jobs,
if you hug them there,
it feels like they've got two basketballs in their chest and it's fucking weird
because it's all scar tissue. But here we go.
Curtis blades and what his homeboys name. Say that name Brendan. No Dude.
Come on dude. Come up. [inaudible] come up up.
Dura came off. Ooh. Big Fellow Curtis blades with a big shot.
The deep shot and his mugshot is out over there. Richard Pryor. Oh Shit.
To go look at this. [inaudible]
crazy. Curtis plays already on his back.
My Boys Harry.
So you've got a good picture of Christie Brinkley's ass.
There must be one out there. I don't think siloed to them. A turn around it
[inaudible] around. It's impossible unless you're doing,
unless she's doing squats every other day at the Olympic training center in
Colorado, it ain't happen. I'm telling you man, you guys are hating on implants.
But there's, there's, there's the Brazilian butt lift, which is an implant.
It's fat from your body into your tolerable. If you got time,
that's what they're doing.
You've got gotta fucking put something in your ass to make it round.
That means you've never worked out and your legs are not going to match that
ass.
But that doesn't work on some girls cause they don't have enough fat for it.
So what they do is they put plastic in there. Those are the implants.
Carol's ass implants do not count. I agree. I would rather,
I would rather marry a chick with a flat out no chick with no a million percent,
no way. Never Fucker doggy style. No, let's go missionary,
go old fashion style.
Never flip her old fashion style. You never flip them in television
style like golden days. Who Do you think was the first guy to fuck a girl?
Doggy style. Like what year Adam
[inaudible] eating an apple. He put the apple on her apple.
Are you kidding? Missionary cabling.
I think missionary started like 200 years ago from the Vatican.
It was like missionary
Curtis Blades Wrestle fucking, I'm gonna die. He can wrestle.
He's a great wrestler. Think about blades. It's like in Ganas. Beat him twice.
The last time he stopped him. You know he stopped him both times.
The last time you stopped him quick.
I feel like a guy like him is in this spot where it's like Kenny ever beat in
Gunno right me. He's a really good wrestler. He's strong as fuck. He's beaten.
A lot of people beat the shit out of Alister over him.
I mean Curtis Blade's a tough, tough dude. Did he play football? No.
Russell Juco. National Champion. Oh yeah. Superstud he's a team. Elevate guy.
Right? Elevation elevation.
So with he a NCAA Division One national champion, a Juco national champion.
What the hell is that? Junior. Junior college. Junior college.
John Jones was juco national champ. Rumble Johnson.
I think a was high up there too. How about rumble Johnson making that come back?
Who? The male handlers? Francis sign me up right now.
That poster would be so sad.
I don't want him to fight someone like Francis and the first fight back.
I want him to make a big statement. It's coming back for sure. Yup. Yup.
That's training.
[inaudible] just posted a video said first time hitting pads in two years. Okay.
Yeah. Don't, don't get him friends. It's ready. One cabin.
I have a feeling like he was itching and then he uh,
did a grappling match against Craig Jones. He got leg locked with the quickness.
Craig Jones locked him up quick.
It probably got real mad and then probably said you didn't want,
I ain't going out like that. Maybe like retired life maybe.
And then the [inaudible] he was like an ambassador for bare knuckle and maybe
just retired. He's like, this shit is boring. I can find a heavyweight.
Well he's in the weed game too.
He's involved somehow or another in some legal marijuana enterprise
that's not going to get your rocks off when people retire.
Like in boxing when people retire, they are like, I got enough money.
All of a sudden I got a couple of Mil, I'll retire.
But then you get used to that couple mil and you're like, damn,
I'm running out of fucking money. I got 700,000 left. Yeah, you're right.
You know what I mean? I got, I got to take another fight. They all come back.
Yeah. [inaudible] still doing the damn thing. Yup.
Fighting for one FC. [inaudible] are they going to drug test him at all? No,
they should. Just to make sure he's on drugs. Just to make sure.
Get your money's worth. We're fighting in the middle of nowhere. Come on man.
There's no way Dana thing give Curtis a title fight. We would fight like this.
Fight fighting my cubby. What's the difference? Well, he's gotta beat Francis.
Francis beat him twice. I mean the only way he's getting a title.
Pfizer Francis wins the title and nobody wants to fight Francis and you look at
those elbows from the Ma [inaudible] Roche.
It's over kid a wrestler and the match is really just,
Oh shit, let's do it. Just like Scott Morris.
Patrick says Shit's rap. His ground pounders.
Phil ferocious too. I don't know if they stopped the fighter though. Oh really?
Yeah. Oh, I thought, oh no, that this is going to go on to say ground. I bet.
Oh, what's that? Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Very cool. Yeah.
They're bringing them to this corner. All,
all these Russians have terrible haircuts, right? They, none of them have here.
A lot of fucking testosterone. Correct. A lot of hair on the body. Not on top.
Boom. You know he's got the craziest is, what's that guy's name? Bruce.
Tom Chev with the guy's name, the wrestler. The grappler dude. He Start
Russ Down Chessy of Chessie f.
That guy is the hairiest man on the face of the planet.
He looks like a bear is one of the beastliness grapplers.
Really killer killer rust of picks people up and throws in Lacrosse Hill and
learn all the terms. He's like a giant Khabib. He's exactly,
exactly covered in hair. Is he doing MMA? He does MMA, but he does.
I don't know exactly what he's doing now. He's fucking Ebi.
He got to the finals and then what happened last at Gordon Ryan,
and over time he got to the finals with Gordon lost in overtime.
Rustam is no joke, but pull up a picture of that dude.
He's literally the hairiest man you're ever gonna see in your life outside of
George, the animal Steele, his name, his arrest them Rustam Chits,
h. I. E. V, I think.
Yeah, he's got a lot of hair on his back. He's a beast,
but Curtis strikings in a lot better too. Ooh. Oh,
we got caught with the upper cut. Just trying to get in there.
Just trying to get to that same position again once he realized he could hold
that guy down and beat the fuck out of him. Played for Steve Pay. Be Fun.
Be Interesting. Steve Bay deals with the Strip melts back in Cleveland.
Now everything's in Cleveland now. Take a picture of
the Cleveland Tobacco June. Are you kidding me? That guy's body.
He looks like a where? Holy Shit. Shit. Find a better picture of him.
There's better pictures. That's nothing. Right. That's certainly shaved.
Tim Clipped. How dare you. Shame. How about that one? There we go.
That's the Russian Russian bear right there. Serious man.
I've ever seen serious grappler.
Holy Shit. I'm trying to get them to do combat Jujitsu. Oh my God.
Look at the hair on it. Up his arms. Good for him.
How many MMA guys who've gotten into combat Jujitsu?
Jesse Taylor,
Josh neer up much near most.
I would say 98% of the guys that do combat Jujitsu have MMA experience.
They're pure Jujitsu.
Grapplers they don't want to have anything to do with combat Jujitsu and that
bad shit.
99% of the guys that I have all have MMA experience.
When did Josh near compete? He was a, when we did, um,
Ebi 17, it was a, the first 16 man Combat Jujitsu tournament we did.
And um, I think, I think he got taken out in the first round.
He's coming back though. He's doing the next one. The next show.
Next Combat Jujitsu is November 24th in it's the middleweights John Thor blank
is the, is a, he won that tournament.
The Josh neer did Josh [inaudible] coming back. John Thor's coming back. Um,
Jesse Taylor's going to do it. The leap of Focalin W it's,
it's going to be an insane November 24th in Mexico and we're on Mexico,
Monterrey, Josh. And here's like one of the forgotten pioneers was killed.
The dentist killer. Yeah. Yeah.
Like when was the last time you found MMA though? It's been a long time, right?
Yeah. So he just decided to compete again. But yeah, combat you get, oh,
it's okay to look at that and said, boy, Curtis is beating the shit out of him.
Last combat you get to show. I did not. You didn't say, oh,
did you guys go get on UFC fight pass and watch the last one, dude, dude,
it was insane. It's a great [inaudible] saying.
It's a great step for guys who are thinking about fighting and MMA and to go
from Jujitsu, MMA or Jujitsu combat, you know,
there's a lot of different ways to look at it. You know, it,
you could look at it as if you're planning on transitioning into MMA and you're
a grappler, it's a great sport.
Or if you're done with MMA and it's too brutal but you still want to compete,
that's a, that's another way to look at it.
I look at it as just the most gangster form of Jujitsu.
Like when you just look at you just to forget about him and that you just look
at Jujitsu and all the different formats. Combat. Jujitsu is the most gangster.
It's the most scary. It's the scariest one. And like I said,
pure Jujitsu grapplers don't want to have anything to do with combat.
Jujitsu was all guys from MMA. They're like, oh sorry. I was going to say that.
All the guys in MMA and the heavyweight division does Curtis blades have the
best ground and pound by fire club by far, by far.
Smashing with specializes up in there.
Katie has a masculine forgot takes right now. So it's still,
he's still in the mix, right? Is he in the middle? He just got, you know,
he came back and got starched [inaudible] no contract. But does he done,
I don't know. He said right now he's focused on a,
the natural Libris stuff and then he's gonna, you know, watch your mouth man.
Is that what's called natural Libra? I'm not, I'm trying to be funny.
Naturally braised the movie. Yeah, that's a Jack Black.
You're going to get online. You Better Watch out. They're coming for you bro.
Oh No. Bring it up bro. Nah, Curtis Moods.
I like his haircut too. You'll hit potholes on the sun to speed them,
knocked him out. Starched him both times. Stopped him in the first fight. No,
he did crazy. Right,
Dr Stoppage that you got a crazy swelling in his,
that was Curtis blades trying to take them down the whole fight. Yes, he was.
And then then the second fight he got starts right away,
frank just swollen and just clipped him.
And that was a big fight for friends looking at me still fives number number
four. Oh yeah, he's, he's right in the mix. I think he knows now more than ever.
I'm just going to guess.
But I think based on his experience in those fights with Francis,
that he realizes, you know what, I just got to be the heavyweight. Could be,
I got to take people
down and smash them on the ground for Steve Bay's very interesting.
It's just hard when he guys stopped you a couple of times in a row, you know,
to these huge giant, I mean, John's tiny though.
Annex freaking tiny. Is He? Yeah, he's, how tall is he? How tall is I in a row?
He's my height. So He's five. No, maybe he's five. Seven. No, he's shorter.
He's shorter than you. Maybe five, seven, five, eight. I'm kidding.
It was in the neighborhood. Your height. When people say you're short, I'm like,
damn, I'm Joe Rogan sign. I'm right there with short five,
nine or nine. He is his back surgery game. An inch type move.
Three quarter inch. I swear to God, I went to the doctor and the fucking,
I had a physical and they measured with [inaudible]. How are you? How is it now?
Not Good. That's a big sign. It's not good. Not, look, I'm not liking that,
you know? Um, before my back surgery,
the pain came from inflammation. So my bad,
no disc and my bones were rubbing together. My l five s one,
or whatever the fuck they call it. So what ends up happening,
there's a problem there and my back. So My, my body, uh,
it inflames the whole lower back just so it's like sore.
So I was living life with just a stiff, frozen back all the time.
Finally got an MRI after years and years, finally got the back surgery.
So now there's a titanium disk in between the two vertebrae,
but my body is still, you know,
cause I'm rolling now and I don't think I'm supposed to,
but I gotta fucking lose weights and I don't know any other way.
I think you're supposed to roll. My Doc,
my doctor told me he doesn't know anything about Jujitsu and he said, he goes,
you okay? What are you doing exactly in this Jujitsu thing? I go, here.
He goes, are people picking you up and slamming you? I said, no, no, no, no, no,
no. They're not picking me up because I'm always pulling guard, you know?
I didn't want to explain that to him because he didn't know what pulling out.
I go, no, no, no, no one's picking me up and slam. And he goes, okay,
that's good, but you're not like twisting or anything, are you? And I said,
twisting. Well my nickname's the twister.
No, we're not twisting. So he goes, as long as you don't twist,
you don't want to do anything.
You don't want to go to the gym and twist your back at all. No twisting at all.
You can't. You can't. No running, no twisting and no snot running,
no running, no squatting, no squatting, no deadlifts. They go you.
We don't want any compression going on in your spine at all.
And no twisting and Jesus.
So what's happening is I'm rolling and my back feels the same.
Like before surgery, like it still hurts. It's still in Flint.
It's still inflamed. So it's my body's going, something's wrong with your back.
What do you think would happen if you got like Regena keen down there?
Right there? I did that. Dude, you have a before, before the surgery you did.
But what about now? That's another 10 K I ain't gonna do that shit again. Yeah,
yeah.
You know what? I'm just, I'm rolling with Limu.
This is the fight Islamic pocket chef.
This is on the fucking Ramos.
This is the fight I'm looking forward to almost as much as the main event. Yeah.
Davi Ramos is, he is the shit and but so is Islam. Islam is a beast. Man.
That guy's so good. DC said he's the heir apparent. He said,
if you see him go with Khabib. He said that motherfucker is a future champion.
I've heard he's an absolute monster in the gym. He's so complete.
Every really striking bunch about Dobie Ramos standup skills.
But if the fight gets on the ground, I'm, I'm, I'm gonna go ahead.
I'm gonna go out on a limb and say it's going to be over. Question.
I don't know. It's not that easy with Davina. I know Davi is, he's a monster.
I don't think it's gonna be that easy though. He's one decisions.
Eddie Dobie Ramos is one decisions against guys who are not as good as Islam.
Okay. Okay. Is this a straight savage? Maybe I'm wrong about Dumbass Davi.
Ramos's record is up. He's a combat sports, uh, you know, world champion.
So He's bursting grappling. Well, he's so good to the Islam as Jujitsu doubt.
No, that could be wrong. It's not anything about his legs. So solid dude,
he's so solid. Like across might be hard to finish. I'll take that back.
I'll take that back. But I just want her to, you know,
say that I'm a giant fan of Davi Ramas Jujitsu.
What he's done in Abu Dhabi's insane. Yeah. So see he's got,
he's got one decision against Austin Hubbard in his last fight.
Who's this drama or eyes. Yeah.
But Sergio MRIs is Shitty fucking Jujitsu fighter.
And Sergio is actually a larger guy. Sergio's Sergio's fighting at one 85.
Was he fighting one 85 or one 70 now?
No 70 but he fought at 85 and the final decisions he find in the finals of the
ultimate fighter Brazil,
he fought 85 against [inaudible] say's are for Hammer.
That was 85 when they fought 70 [inaudible] Neil magni and you guys will choke
the OMEGAMON starts by wrong some arm bar.
I'm going to say Dobby Ramos arm bar right now.
All I'm saying is he's won a bunch of submissions,
but he submission Nick Piedmont, you know,
he'd decision Nick Piedmont decision and this Austin Hubbard character in those
last fight so that he went three rounds with that cat.
That was a good fight to Austin. Hubbard's a good fighter.
That was a really good fight. Half-Full Rick Lee in the back. Um,
so I don't know if he's going to submit them quick.
I think my coach has the best fighter. He's fought. Yeah, I really do.
I would assume he's in your boys and underdog Eddie. Goddammit.
Brendan. So you got to Piss on my, I'm not dude that hey, I'm,
how's Victor's back? Cause Victor had the same surgery as you, right? Yeah,
he came in last week. How's his back? Uh, his was a little different than mine.
Right. You'd be surprised that like when you, when you, um,
when I went to have back surgery, my doctor showed me
X-ray's of all these different backs. He goes, do they all look way different?
Like everyone's back is so different and some people have fucked up backs.
They never done anything athletically their whole life. So it's like, uh,
his was different than mine. Mine, Mine, mine was worse than,
but Islams of 400 minus 400 favorite. He's,
I think he's the biggest favorite on the card. Decides can dammit.
I didn't know anything about Islam. Oh Dude, he's so good.
If you talk to anyone who's in like the circles, he's like the next,
I think he's the Barry Parent. God Damn, he's a fucking nightmare.
So I can I take back my prediction? No, no. Take it back. No, no, no, no.
I gotta commit to it once you say something, you stick with it for life.
And we didn't bet on this. We didn't bet on it. We could've hustled
Callan, Callan Shop Bucks, 20 bucks. He might not never be here.
He said he was going to be done at 11,
but he's probably the one shop right now picking up vintages
when they say you're done at 11, when you're filming a TV show. I bet you,
I bet you he doesn't make it. I bet she doesn't make it. So what,
let me ask you this. What was the difference from Victor's back in your back?
It just looked different. My,
you had to qualify physically for this to,
for, um, disc replacement. If you don't qualify for district placement,
your bones gotta be a certain way. Then they just fuse it.
Then they just fucking put like a metal cage in your spine and just screw it
all. That's what cane got. Yeah. So fusion is, that's hardcore. Uh, but the,
the alternative is dis replacement. It all depends how your bone sit.
And I was right, dude. I was right. He was showing me, my doctor said, dude,
your bear, you're barely qualifying for district placement. You want to do it.
It's on you. I, it was dude, it was a game time decision. Um,
I decided whether I was going to go fusion or disk right before surgery.
Right before they put me out. Oh my God, that's coming to dead right.
Sorry to interrupt you guys. Is your decision not mine. Cause I was on the,
on the fence.
I was like on the borderline and I decided to go with the [inaudible]
replacement. So there's a risk.
There's a risk of if you're not qualified physically and you'd go ahead and do
it, shit could fall apart.
Like what is the qualification though?
That's what I'm confused on what your bones are sitting like. If your,
if your vertebrae are like,
I'm like a horizontal, then you're good.
But if you're like this, if your vertebrate it, some people are like,
they're like,
no we got a fuse that motherfucker cause it's slipping off your shit.
Oh so it's so, so cockeyed that it's like poking into the side of your body.
It's simplified.
It's just if you're horizontal and there's something that it's laying on,
it's good. But if you're like this, mine was like this.
My back was like they were ready to just fuse it.
But the problem with it, if you get fusion in five years,
you've got to fuse the vertebrae on top of it five years later.
We've got a few of the other ones, so your back's just going to be metal.
I know a girl, she used to work at the store. A whole back's fused. Yeah.
She had some something fucked with it and you go fusion.
You just get it every five years. You got to get more bro. She walked like this.
Yeah. Everything was like this. It was like she had a pole from her head.
She still did, but no, she was like this so,
but other than my back did,
I had shoulder surgery and knee surgery and those motherfuckers aren't 100%
either. I don't.
I think at 50 when you're 50 I don't think you'll ever recover 100% you still on
the TRT? A little bit. What about stems? You say you're doing stem cell too?
No, no, no, no, no, no. You got to do that. I'm not thinking.
I guarantee you you did that.
That fixed that shoulder guaranteed you about to get in my foot for my planner.
You still have plantar fasciitis horribly. You still running? Yeah, I'd have to.
You have to. I just love it. Why don't you get one of them? Zero runners.
Have you seen nothing that I have out here is a Woodway. No, no, no. It's a,
it's like a weird sort of like an a lip. Sorry,
sorta like an elliptical machine, but you, you're, it's,
you're actually doing it as a run. The movement.
The movement is the same as running. It'd be cool. I swim. I just got it here.
Try it. Try it. Try it. I like to run outside though. I like hiking. I do too,
but I mix it up. I mix it up with that. I mix it up with the air runner,
which is a runner that you push yourself. You, you.
That's how it's like a tank tire. I'm back tank track now. Swimming,
swimming every week, man. You go somewhere to do that or do you have a baby?
Do you go back? I'm sorry. Back.
I'm doing the exact same routine I did for the metamorris fight to try and lose
weight. Trying to lose weight, trying to get my cardio together, dude, dude,
my cardio is the worst. But what about exercises on your back?
What about using like a reverse hyper I do.
And all these different things up your back. No, I do. You Go, here we go.
I do back extensions. $20 a day. Regularly. You guys, Bam.
And the last one, it's my guys a minus 400 look,
Dhabi Ramos can win this fight 100% anything can happen, man.
Dhabi Ramos gets you on the ground. He's a legit multiple time world champion,
legit. And he's got real fucking power in his hands.
Dobie Ramos is a dangerous striker. He really is. I mean,
he's not like a helpless guy on his feet.
He's explosive will fuck you up on the feet.
I just think that market chef is by far the most complete fighter he's ever
faced. A motherfucker, man. He's so technically proficient.
Who is he? Who is he beat? What are his biggest wins? Well that last guy,
Armando tarts. Sorry. Yuki and that guy that he beat is a really young kid.
He's like 20 and he's a fucking phenom too.
That guy is a future world champion as well. You talked to anyone around AK.
They'll, they'll tell you this guys that a k two oh,
trains could be right here and yeah, him and could be. Go at it, dude.
I've called some of his fights before. Man. I'm super impressed with him, dude.
He's 20 take Davi down. Yeah, good idea. At least threatening, right?
The Samba combat world champion. Yeah,
but you don't want to take it down or you want to stay on your feet with Davi.
Think about big mistake Javi
too. Is Dhabi is a Goddamn tank. I mean that guy's so strong. He's explosive,
man. Look in the back on that motherfucker. To me, this is the best fight.
Besides the main event. The most intriguing fight. Yes. I've been looking at,
when I found out this was signed, I was like, Oh,
you guys did we talk about his armbar and Abu Dhabi that flying armbar he did.
No, I've seen it though. It's amazing. Filthy dude. He's so good.
He's so good and he's so dynamic, so explosive. Who, who's the best right now?
And I didn't like straight Brazilian Jujitsu like Dre Shesha Still Marcella
Garcia is still the best. He's still training and fighting competition.
Guys that are competing like is Boucher or like Cyborg?
Are those guys still doing the dish and shuts fucking everybody up?
I'm such good. Felipe at Penn Yad Gordon Ryan.
I Love Gordon Ryan back from his knee surgery. Yup.
I love going competing already.
He just competed in some new quintet type of [inaudible] he's called to his leg
was ripped apart just like four months ago and then amazing. Oh Shit.
Damn. There's so many good guys right now. Dude.
There's so many fucking [inaudible].
Has there ever been a better time for grappling? Oh, that's really incredible,
man. He could guys, dude,
they're all over the place and Craig Jones is not doing MMA right?
He's just fighting a Jujitsu tournaments. Is that correct? Yes. He's not doing,
I remember he's one of the best two Craig Jones doing of course Geo Martinez,
right? Tom PJ Barsh is one of my guys. Barch sorry.
I would say blowers. Lucky is fighting. Um, Rafael Lovato. Phil Lavato.
Ooh, wow. That's good. We got a lot of bad motherfuckers at 10 planet
that was just a super brown belt,
absolute tournament yesterday with all the best brown belts from around the
world. And in the finals, both guys were turned planet guys,
Kyle bame and Chase Hannah. So Woo. 10th Pine in the home.
We may not be the best, but we're trying.
Look at this fucking did you know who nobody wants to fuck with and you don't
hear much about him cause he just steamrolls everyone's Ryan Hall. Oh,
it looks like an accountant,
but no one wants to fuck this manager's trying to get them on the podcast where,
you know, he's a smart dude. Until when he was great. Eric Ryan Hall. Ryan Hall.
It's fuck with reminds me a lot of fabrics. River doom in the sense that,
um, a lot of Jujitsu guys, a lot of high level Jujitsu guys,
when they make the transition to MMA, um, you know, it,
it's gonna take a while to get your striking together.
So a lot of guys come in and they, they get, it's just too rough.
And the striking is just, they're just too far behind. So they just say,
you know what? Fuck it. I'm going to dip out and focus on Jujitsu.
I've got plenty, there's plenty of money and running Jujitsu schools.
But then there's guys that stay and they get their strike and together,
cause if you don't, if you remember when Barb Isa for doom,
when he first started, he wasn't that great or this awkward.
It wasn't that great. He wasn't that great of an MMA fighter,
but he stuck it out. He's so,
he stuck it out and then little by dude, his striking becomes legit.
And that's what's going on with Ryan Hall. Ryan Hall.
He doesn't read any vertical and fuck.
But that's why he's so good because his striking is they can't get a matchup.
They can get close to Ryan Hall because he's [inaudible],
he'll throw head kicks at you and he's throwing shit and staying on the outside.
So Ryan Hall stuck it out. He didn't quit.
He could have easily quit MMA and just said, fuck it.
I'm running my Jujitsu school. I had made 50 k a month. You know what I mean?
But stuck it out. He stuck it out and now it's happening.
You're seeing the rise of Ryan Hall, right? Kind of. They can't get the matches.
He, there's no marketing used to. It's too scary. It's,
you know your kids rip your fucking ankle off. Yeah,
because he does hate to take you there. This fight is heating up.
Dobby Ramos is clipped Islam with a big right hand. Oh duty. Yeah,
he's dangerous man. Hey, back the volume though for doom top five of all time.
I think if you look at his record, what he's done on top five,
you'll get enough credit before his last few fights.
I would have put him in number one. I had him number one until he lost,
when he beat, when he beat Cain Velasquez. You got to think, okay,
here's the guy who beat fade or Noguera n Cain Velasquez,
three of the greatest of all times submitted all of them. I mean, how do you,
how do you not have that guy? Now people forget too,
when he fought Travis Brown on Fox.
It was like the third or fourth big Fox fight that was Travis brown in his
prime. I think Travis ranked like three in the world and
[inaudible] let's Travis done. Have you talked to him? No,
I don't mean him don't speak. No, I, I dunno,
I would that I think he worked for Rhonda. I think he did like, man,
it helps her with like our merchant stuff. Who they're good man.
You know what I'm saying? I think, yeah, there's plenty of money.
There's no need to fight. No, don't need to get punched in the face. But I,
I think with Verdo man, he was people. He was so good.
He's my favorite man. I just got his love for doing this car.
He was so nice to come a while to get going. It took him a while.
It was a hard transition cause when he first started [inaudible] doom was like,
his striking was like, oh shit, I got it. I got to get this fight to the ground.
Well he came in, now he's a legit movie. Ty. Are you kidding me?
Some amazing Mark Hunt. He's amazing.
But you remember when Julia knocked him out?
Remember junior k owed him with an uppercut.
That's when junior like burst on the scene. Yeah. Oh God.
I forgot about that uppercut.
That was junior was an assassin when he was first fighting.
Then you're seeing that. You're seeing that too.
Another guy who didn't give up and it keeps pushing and little by little that
strikings gang deadly. Vinny Maga last CJ pen on this job.
Don't forget about big Vinny. Mines the less cause that guy dude, he's,
Oh look at this. Oh Shit. Dobby Ramos is throwing some heats on.
He's looking for the take down. Kenny. Get it dude.
Vinnie Michael as the guard twice in the same night and and with two victories
in that PFL visa freak man.
The World Guard twice in one night and two victories. Yeah, he's good.
Lost in that finals. You know what? That million dollar,
if you know what he learned a lot from that dude. He's, he's any dude.
Have you seen him lately? Did he show
Bratty, shredded? He got his cardio to be this scary dude. He got it and he's,
he's like [inaudible]. He just keeps going.
He doesn't give up and little by little he's fucking knocking dudes.
I would head kicks. You can't sleep on Vinny? No, he's elite.
How old is Vinnie now?
I would say 34 so he's right there.
He bursts on the UFC and just wasn't ready. Wasn't ready yet.
Striking wasn't ready. It is.
His problem has always been cardio once and I always tell him, I go, dude,
once you, you conquer your cardio problem,
you're going to be fucking hard to deal with for anybody.
That was a good left-hand of the body by Mokatrov. He's mixing it up. That was,
that was a slick move.
He's been throwing them all the head and dobby put his hands up and he went
right to the rib cage.
This is a interesting fight, man. Very interesting. Cakewalk is,
is this the second round? Yes. I haven't been on the ground at all. Right? No,
no. I'd love for it to go to the ground though. No, I mean,
both guys have tried too, which is interesting that my coach,
I've tried to bring it to the ground.
Is it just anneken Dominick Cruz doing the chemistry? Yeah. Yeah.
Just two man crew. God [inaudible] go home.
They got that guy going everywhere. Kids go home to give them a break.
This his Gig, man, now he loves it. I don't think he was in China for,
for John Wailey didn't want him.
Did he catch him or was he going for a take down? It's hard to tell.
I was hard to tell there. Um,
how about Wally? John or John Whaley? They like to check. Yeah.
The one who fucked up starts on drudge. I didn't see the fight.
Was it legit or low? Beat the shit out. Easily. Shit over 40 seconds.
[inaudible] Stryker or what? Killer man. Just fucking straight 2020 and one.
She's like 20 in a row. She's a monster. She caught her with a right hand,
hurt her and then finish her while she in one FC. Um,
she's beating bitches up somewhere, but she, uh, maybe, maybe,
I gotta be honest. I'd never heard of her until that and I was like, oh,
[inaudible] going to steamroll. Oh really? No, her never seen her fight.
I don't thought women's fighting that dude. She's fucking like,
you need to change that. Then you get a d, people get mad at you,
but you're talking shit about the strawweight division. I don't know.
I'm sure I don't care.
I have a fight show and then if it's kind of, I have a fight.
It's like a lifestyle show. Not like others fights this weekend.
I know she is on draws for the win. That's how cover it. This is a dobby.
Ramos is pushing the pace here.
I mean Davi is the one who's constantly moving forward here and he's,
he's trying to counter and throw these explosive bombs,
but Islam is using good footwork and good movement. You know what dive is,
right? Eyes Cut. Yep. Nice movement there in the clench,
obviously just coming up short.
He's throwing that jab and then the big right hand,
but [inaudible] Chavez moving just enough away. That's slight fight IQ
and he's popping that jab at him. It's real technical fight very well.
That's how Maka Chubb fights man, his, his whole game is to,
and he's only 27 that's the other thing about Mokatrov dude.
That's why I think in the main event with Khabib,
you know it could be we'll fuck around a little bit and play the ego game and
strike with you. I think his dad's in his corner now. He's, he like,
we ain't doing that. We're not taking any of these risks.
And he listened to his dad.
Well I think you can get a full onslaught of could be grappling.
It's also this fucking heat man. Dominic Cruz says the hottest place on earth.
That's not exactly what he said. John. Let's be honest.
Something that Matt saw that arena
[inaudible] something like that.
Look at, see Davi, he's swinging these punches but his entry is short.
He landed a hammer fist on his forehead. How old is Ramos?
32 so Islam's 27 Davi started to,
he's just like in his entry, it's,
it's a lot of these guys particularly like Jujitsu guys, the,
even though they are developed power,
they don't necessarily spend a lot of time on footwork.
Footwork is so crucial for your ability to move in and move out.
Did you see Campbell vs Lama? Chanko? Yes. Woo.
That's all foot wear baby. Good fight though. Yeah.
Campbell brought him as he did. That wasn't a cakewalk. Work is overrated. Ha.
That's hilarious. It took you to something.
I was like, what's happening right now?
That dude brought about foot work. Dude foot works everything, man.
Footwork's everything. You know,
one of the interesting things about watching a guy with really good footwork is
you could see his opponent like doesn't necessarily know what,
how he caught him on, dude. It dropped him and then he,
he went for a take down. It was like a good acting. Yeah. He,
well he was in the area. It was like survival. Yeah. Reaction.
But Maka Cheff definitely landed more. That was a big shot though.
Dhabi's fucking dangerous man. But look, it's becoming more of a striking fight.
Look out fucking, he's Ah, he's got his mouth open too, man.
That's how hot it is in that joint.
I'd love to see him just grappling and understand why they don't have better ac.
The musters that they have at like a universal studios while you're waiting in
line. How cool would that be? Well then everybody be greasy as it would be wet.
That'd be tear people slapping. Fuck, they're all sweaty anyway, man.
I mean how much wet are you going to get?
Nobody wants to see that shit on the ground anyways.
You approach through the burn. Oh,
it's so [inaudible].
Oh Shit. Oh Wow.
I got some times. Cat Graham, Helen, right. That's that combat thumb.
Low ground and pound on. Damn son. Dad, look, he's calling.
He's blessed London. He's busted up. He's going to London right there.
Look at that. Let's see if he could pull anything off,
man. I mean he's gotta be exhausted right here. Yeah, look,
mock chap pulls right out. Pops right out of there. So Greasy. Yeah, so greasy.
Let's see if Debbie could pull something off though. Dude,
he's going to go for a truck. How many of these these guys,
traditional Jujitsu guys who are embracing rubber guard,
how many of them come to you to try to learn some of this stuff because of the
fact it's like the best thing to do when you're in a position where someone's
really greasy,
you actually have control of your own leg and you can control someone's body and
you know still it helps if they're [inaudible]. People are coming to me crazy.
I'm not that man. I would imagine like this. This is a not a bad idea,
but it's not as good. Yeah. If you, if you're still doubting,
if rubber guard is the jet guy, go to the Instagram rubber guard assassins,
go to that and then just look at those clips and then tell me if it's
legitimate. That's a dope Instagram page. Rubber guard assassins.
I'm there every day, every day. It's just a reminder.
That's one of my spots I go to every day to see what's up a calendar on its way.
By the way, allegedly count up the cheese store right now, sniffing a dress,
helping these, helping them right now. Dude, Jamie.
Oh, was that an early knockout?
That was that guy who I said got to start legs were shaking.
Did you see his legs? He hit him right behind the air, dude,
his legs were vibrating. Yeah, man. Let him run.
The equilibrium that happens on [inaudible] does filthy though.
You know when Valentina Shevchenko head kicked Jessica, I dude,
she was down and out for so long and her legs were doing this little twitching
thing like this here sound like a bat. Woo.
That girl Valentine. Shevchenko you know, uh, I was talking to gas, Tom Bolanos.
He came backstage to my show in San Francisco and we were talking and he said
something that I totally agree with.
He said she might have one of the highest iqs fight Iqs in any division.
Oh No. Female. A hundred percent a hundred percent she's so good.
She's so goddamn good. She's setting her up with that body kick, whack, whack,
and then dawn at, Ooh,
right off the coconut bar on that left arm.
But look at the Russians left elbow. Not In a good spot for dobby.
He needs to get that elbow in before he goes to Davi. A good guard player.
You know what I don't know. Yeah. He's,
I'm known for strangling people and arm bars and shit. His top games like high,
super high level, but I haven't really seen him fight off his back.
Yeah. He's, he's struggling here. Little risk control. Let's see.
He was guy looking for the Camorra oh leg going through.
Uh Oh that was sneaky. I liked that.
Setting them up for the camera and the right arm but going for the arm bar on
the left. Hey Joe, has a dumb Cruz talked to you about coming back and fighting.
Yes. He's on his way. Yeah, he's coming back.
He's trying to get a fight with south udo triple cs. Great fight. Yeah.
And they're talking a lot of shit to each other, but they're making that fight.
That's fight Benevidez he does. That's what Dana said. 25 yeah.
Or vacate did.
The only problem with that is like what if someone gets injured would've
benefited as he gets injured. True. So this is interesting right here.
Cause Davi has control of his leg and Islam is on top of him.
Not much time to work for Davi, man. Not looking good. Yeah. I think,
I think the decision was,
well this is why you realize why Islam is a 401 I don't have to pay your 20
bucks to 20 down. It's just kind of fun in the moment.
[inaudible] pay the money, Bro. This is nonsense. It's not fair.
People are watching minus 400 people are watching like you really,
I don't have to pay it. Let's just keep tabs. What? What does Dhabi do here?
Eddie? Tell me what to do. If you were in Dhabi's corner,
we should control that orchard. That orchard really
is that harder to do on slippery folk? Dude,
dead orchard is the most common submission in Jujitsu history.
A submission from your back in the history of Jujitsu.
Really there's more dead orchard armbars than any other kind of Armbar from the
garden. Any kind of style of grappling. Where's dead?
Orchard armbars going on all day.
Everywhere around the world there's a Instagram called dead Orchard Society.
Dude, they're everywhere and you don't see like regular,
traditional armbars anywhere these days.
When was the last time you seen an Armbar from the guard in Abu Dhabi?
I could think of to Shante. Roberto. He's got a good close guard.
Armbar and chrome. Gracie. That's it. That's it.
You never see armbars from the garden.
Nathan Orchard's invention. Did he get really good at it? He invented it. Yep.
That's amazing.
It's amazing when one guy finds a move that's so effective.
Yeah.
Nathan Orchard is a bad motherfucker,
dude. 29 28 bang. Look at that.
So pretty clearly Islam on this fight. Yeah. Yeah.
That's my most excited. Seattle. Nathan Orchard. Just a little shout out.
Sorry about that. And so who's running Portland? That's Phil Schwartz.
That's another fucking monster do we got monsters everywhere, dude.
All over the world. Isn't it crazy? Love all that shit.
Started out the bomb squad. Yeah, Dude. Memorizing back in the day.
I got killers all over the goddamn world. Every day I wake up,
I'm like, how the fuck did that happen? You know who looks fucking great, Ralph.
Ralph tearing. Look at you falling Ralph.
I've talked to 10 plant a borough in old school. Dude,
I used to hate rolling with that guy. He was way bigger back then too.
It was really like he's, he's leaned out. He's shredded.
If you see the picture that he posted, 55 years old. Yeah. Full six pack.
Shred it back. He's a super athlete and constantly working. Constantly training,
you know, Rout Ralph was before the whole leg lock revolution.
Ralph Victor, um, and Amir,
they were all training with um,
CSW and Josh Barnett and Eric Paulson.
They were my leg lock guys. I like, I like what crew? My leg block cruel.
I thought I was balls deepen the last time victor caught me.
He caught me with a heel hook. Yeah, those are my black guys.
And then when the leg lock revolution busted out, I realized shit,
I'm not doing enough. Like I thought I was doing plenty with leg locks. We were,
he looking all the Goddamn time and 10th planet.
But then once Ebi took off and we re, I realize, Oh shit,
I'm not doing enough leg locks. I thought I was, but I'm not.
So I fixed that shit. Was I do telling them what to say.
Call somebody up. Probably.
Probably don't forget to thank the prime paying you shit Brendan. No,
you don't owe me shit man. You owe him 20 bucks.
I don't give a fuck about that shit.
How come you're so aggressive about not paying? I don't pay bets.
What do you want to do? Nothing.
Let me get back to you back since this is over ready cause I'm very curious
about, I'm gonna poke you in the it has,
has anybody ever gotten that disc replacement thing and then gone into
athletics? Gone back? That's a good question. I don't know. I'm trying man.
Cause I, you know, rolling with little dudes trying to get in there.
I'm trying to get my shit together cause you know when you're teaching Jujitsu,
when you're teaching and you're not rolling,
there's a big difference man.
Because if you're not rolling there's so much shit that you forget.
You know when you roll every time I'm rolling.
Even when it's like little blue belts and stuff, I'm like, oh,
I remember that little transition. I got to teach that. Oh, I remember that one.
Ooh, I don't remember this. I remember that because if you're not rolling dude,
it's like you like if you're teaching and you're not rolling all your
experiences just like plateau. That's it. You don't, you don't, you don't,
you can't, it's so hard to evolve and progress if you're not rolling.
So man, I'm just trying to roll just to keep my teaching uh,
evolving. Yeah. Stop Rolling Dude. You're frozen.
And it's like teaching a language but not talking. Exactly. It's that.
It's so important. You gotta keep rolling.
So I physically and I'm probably not supposed to be rolling,
but um, a couple times a week, like twice a week I roll in.
Have you had your back looked at since you said that it's in pain?
I'm afraid you're afraid. Like some shits loose and I'm afraid I don't, I don't.
So it's going to happen. How do you feel right now?
Like sitting there right now. I'm fine.
It doesn't hurt right now when it hurts us. If I stand for too long.
I remember back in the day of the comedy store when I would stand, they go,
where's daddy yet? And Joe Gall, he's sitting down somewhere.
His back's fucked up. I would have to,
I couldn't stand for more than 15 minutes. This was four years.
This was like you can stand
and stand for Lee to Joe. It's a, he's sitting down somewhere early.
Two thousands he couldn't stand. I couldn't stop. I can't,
I can't stand like in one spot for more than like 1520 minutes without my back
freezing up. Fuck man. It's tough. Crazy. It's tough.
So when I'm shooting down pumps, I went up and teaching.
Now I'm teaching and if I'm just standing around teaching af like within a half
an hour I got to sit down and start stretching my hamstrings cause you get
tight. What do you do to now let me ask you this.
If you strengthen all those muscles,
like significantly strengthening the muscles in your back. Listen man,
this place is open to you anytime you want to use it.
There's a reverse hyper machine. There's a bunch of back things up,
gets inflammation that I'm dealing with. It's not,
it's no standing weak muscles. It's inflammation. I understand.
But some of that can be mitigated by these machines and strengthened killers.
No, no, no, no. Fuck that. I'm this. And then the other thing is sauna.
Anytime you want to use a sauna here, go sit in that sauna.
That'll reduce inflammation. Big Time. You know what Cryo most is?
When I jump in a pole and I swim, take the weight off of it.
It's like a, it's like the coolness of the pool.
It's like doing cardio in a pole. Dude.
When I'm doing sprints and I'm dead tired, I'm out at the pool.
I'm going to fucking pull and I'm automatically being cooled off in a pool.
It's the best for me. Like swimming is everything for me. Right.
You see that football player who when the crowd chamber and did it where the
booties and he stayed in there for like four talking about that right before the
podcast. Oh really? Yeah, the good. The guy was his name Jay Antonio Brown.
He got done today cause he's an asshole.
But he's the best player in the game and he had a Madison for Dell Beckham Jr.
Okay. Shut the fuck up. [inaudible] Brown, right? Stats beg to differ.
Best catch of all time.
The Best Kachin NFL history was by who the giants were seeing how bad Kyrie
David tied, right? No, no, no, no, no. Oh No. Beck him.
When he goes back with that one with one hand, that's great. I'm like this,
but the homeboy did in the Superbowl. Come on man. No, no.
That's the best catch in NFL history. That's Odell Beckham.
Any radio jumper in case it gets cold inside. In the event
they said to the UMC fighting fan experience,
they built this arena specifically for UFC events. Someone's,
they're going to take someone and drag them into the woods with a camel.
Oh Dude, do you mean the Sand Dragon? Let's say someone's done fucked up.
They might make their own woods out there. Do you know Abu Dhabi?
They make it rain. They're once a year on purpose. Excuse me.
Once a week they cloud see 50, 50, two times a year. They have,
they built their own islands too. Yeah. Yeah, they did though. That's a,
that's Dubai actually is by has a, uh,
a crazy island that's shaped like a palm shaped like the world. Yeah.
Like palm tree. But it has,
it's like each one of them represents the different continents. Yeah.
It's really kind of crazy. Some of them are melting, right?
Like the sense like the water's taken away.
People have these huge cribs on them.
Can't really fight nature of hurricanes in that area. I do not.
I don't think so. I don't think so. Did you hear were criticizing
Tyler Perry because Tyler Perry sent a bunch of, um,
resources down to The Bahamas, a bunch of supplies,
but he did it in his private jet.
He sent his own jet filled with products and people like, you know,
that's the height of celebrity ignorance.
You're using a private jet and it's contributing to global warming. I'm like,
how the fuck
do you think that they're going to get these things down there?
Listen people who such Edwards UFC legend. Yves Edwards.
He's from The Bahamas. Yes. And he's like,
he's trying to rally as many people as possible to help to go down there.
Go to eve. It's a at Thug Jujitsu. Jensen.
A tug Jitsu Thug Jitsu on Instagram.
If you want to donate and help the people out. Is it a go fund me?
It's some kind of donation. Cause just the dude.
Have you seen the drone footage of that island? That Bosco Island? Dude,
it looks like a bomb got dropped. There's Eve. Wow, look at that. That's crazy.
That looks like the, there you go. Thug thug.
But to master to two master, but it Miss Florida, right?
It went right past Florida. Yeah,
but it was on the way to Alabama according to Trump. Did you see that? No,
we're Trump drew. Like they, they told Trump,
Trump said it's on the way to Alabama and they were like, no, it's not.
So he shows a map of the hurricane and then with a sharpie he had drawn a line
like headed towards Alabama. It's like, look,
I know like what the fuck are you talking about? Dude? People were watching,
looking at the picture like Kyle Kalinsky was,
he had it up on his howling howling at this.
Like Trump just added a sharpie can just drew a class line. It's classic,
but Jamie, didn't you say it may or may not be like against the law,
what he did like against the law to alter a federal forecast or something like
that. That's out bullshit. They're not going to do anything to him.
That's fucking bullshit. What does that on CNN and talking shit on Trump
[inaudible] I know on CNN, they're all over Trump for that shit.
They need to shut the fuck up at CNN, you know this was CNN.
Fox News was making fun of it too, Dude. Everybody having every fondness to no,
look, Eddie, everyone was making fun of it. He literally drew a lot.
It's just funny, the guy didn't want to be proven wrong.
He said there was going to Alabama.
The forecasters did not say he was going out. He missed little area.
So he took a piece of paper with the forecast and drew an extra little line,
a little loop headed towards Alabama because he knows it's funny.
Look at the sharpie line, the bubbles. He's like, look, see,
I told you the forecasts. Look,
do the people around like dog dentists, they can all fly, man.
There's some people going to see the people around him will not deny that he did
it. Do you know, do you know that island that got hit? Do you know that, uh,
the conspiracy theory? I Dunno. It's, oh
no. This conspiracy on hurricanes hitting. Yeah. Wow.
What are they conspiracy? They're so crazy. And the Epstein and all that shit.
It's so crazy. None of that was hurting with Epstein Epstein happening.
Dude. You guys gotta be opened at fucking everything. Okay.
Tell us about the heredity opened the efforts about the hurricane Eddie.
I don't know, man. You guys don't want, Oh, I'll do it.
And I [inaudible] ever heard one of hurricane, I believe in Epstein.
I believe in fucking a ton of stuff. I don't know, man. Eddie,
you guys, you guys, you guys, uh, he get mad about Trump. He's,
that's what got him. These are Trump supporters. Trump,
Trump trying to fucking save this country and they're fucking crazy left is
trying to fucking put transgenders in, in elementary schools. Okay,
so that's, you guys don't believe whatever the fucking was simple,
simplified narrative. But I assume what you're saying like come on man. Poverty.
Here we go. Pull filter. Paul Felder.
Barboza to Paul Felder is a big Jackin lightweight.
He has a shorts to keep them high and tight, Bro. Yeah.
I don't know why anybody would wear shorts that are loose because it gives
someone an opportunity to grab them. Also just mobility. Yeah. Boxers.
Why does where I'm so bad?
Shorts mean you could grab them because people just do grab them.
It doesn't mean that it's illegal, but they do. But nobody grabs tights.
I mean if someone grabs tight,
so you literally go to grandma fucking tight to check on the lifts for little
shreds. I says, pads, I'm going to grab your tights.
That's what happened in metamorris too. There was like a big fucking,
it was some bullshit ass legal shit going on with that.
Like cause I was wearing pants and Heuler was wearing tights.
They said since you're, you're wearing pants heuler can grab them.
And I said okay, if he could grab my pants, I'm going to grab his shorts.
No you can't grab shorts. Look like he's grabbing my pants.
Why can't I grab his shorts?
Because the shorts are form fitting and your pants are loose. Hey Jamie,
can you bring up Barboza Lincoln few fights? No, no, no.
It doesn't make any sense that I was in the middle of everything to try to get
you to lose it. Crazy shit where I had to go at the very end, I'd go,
okay you could grab my motherfucking pants and I won't grab your fucking shorts.
It got to that. Is that how you left it? I'm like what Brad?
My motherfucking path.
Cause I'm trying to make it legal for him to grab my pants because they weren't
form fitting but I couldn't grab his shorts because they were formed fits.
You ever find out how bad his knee is, bro. His knee.
I will never forget that. Sit in there walk cause I was live. I was right there.
I was watching you wrench his knees sideways and I was just going, oh
I was thinking he's going to tap any second now and it's going pop, pop, pop,
pop, pop, pop. Yeah. He didn't tap.
That shit popped all over the place and animal and he tap. He's an animal.
The fact that you can tap, it's been tough for him.
Lust videos last for Shark Winnie. That's be fake, right?
No, you got
[inaudible]. Who the fuck shark? Winnie. Who is Shark Winnie Click on shirt.
Dan. That's great bro. What do you mean it's fake? Barboza verse winning.
He never headline in March 30 that's fake.
And now they just got someone to spot for his jacket. Who's shark?
Winnie as the greatest jacket ever. It fake. It's a fake. It's fake Joe. Yeah,
because his last fight he knocked out Dan Hooker. Right. Is that real?
There's no guy named Dan Hooker. Just engage with Kao to him in his last fight.
Yeah.
So who is this kind of a crossroads where Barboza someone fuck with Wikipedia
and got us to say it. They got us
some lost Felder. Lost fatherless.
Barboza Barboza little mud fight though, bro.
He was hitting him with this switch.
K everything that was like literally like he was moving through time.
This kind of a crossroads for buyer Bose though. You look at this kind of,
you know what I'm saying? Girls for Felder, two men.
Felder got beat by Mike Perry. Broke his arm,
had to get his arm bolted together again. Was that his last fight?
That's his last fight, right? Mike Perry Felder's going to be fine.
Those are commentator. Oh, he's a great comment. I love him as a kid.
His mind is so sharp too. Just not having any problems at all.
And He's got a fucking chin, like a piece of rock [inaudible] description.
A piece of rock. What does that, oh, I saw it too last night.
How was it fucking legit man? Was it the ending? A little dicey.
Stephen King sucked from who? Um, I don't know.
Probably same people that hated Dave Chappelle's comedy special for,
especially for being what? Dave Chappelle's comedy special.
Who did the Chris Media. Did you hear what social media? No, no, no, no.
Critics. This is what happened. It's ridiculous on rotten tomatoes. So good.
So good. The critics put it on.
They put it on rotten tomatoes and rotten tomatoes only let five critics judge
it and they gave it as 0% they didn't have it open to the public and people were
furious and they were, okay, here we go. The fight side.
Then they open it up to the public. You got 99% which parties?
Nothing gets [inaudible]. Chappelle crushed that shit. Of course.
Steve Chappelle, so Paul Felder, Ooh, look at that. Right away.
Barboza was showing spinning shit. That low calf kick and then oh my,
these boys are brings it baron. Was it because of that LBGT bit? Oh yeah,
definitely. A lot of it fell to just top. Just touched him with, oh shit.
There's that switch kick these boys, they're trying to go to the judges.
Are they? That switch kicked at Barboza throws is the best in the game.
His switch kick to the body is fucking insane, dude.
Barboza is 10 is way better than Felder's. It's a lot better.
Look at that Tan Felder's that Philly white boy founders putting that fucking
pressure on them. Huh? Look at that. That low calf kick. Oh,
everybody's throwing that Felder's thrown heat.
Barbosa has a speed advantage for sure. Oh yeah, for short.
But he hasn't over almost everybody. He's so fast.
But they ever on the close down first fight. I don't believe that.
I don't think so. I think it was mostly a lot of this. I think that'd be tragic.
Felder's not taking anybody down. He cracks with everybody.
Look at this though.
Try and take him down and he might just be threatening him cause it's hot as
fuck out there. He's trying to wear him out.
[inaudible] I don't think it's that hot out there, man.
I think you blown it out of proportion. Well Dominic crew sounds 120 oh,
there's blood. If someone's got blood, look, it's all over a Barboza.
His left arm is Felder. Cut Hashtag in Abu Dhabi.
Nice. Where's that? It's right there on the day. That's important to them.
The ring links that goddamned in the ring in the cage. Oh, Ooh.
Left Hook over the top. Where is the, Ooh, that leg kick and again,
damn Felder. Zite nose checked it though. Oh, Sham.
Left-Hand Bro. He's going to drop.
Someone's getting knocked out after I've took connect.
Son Felder is bound and determined to get this back and after he got killed by
[inaudible], he thinks that Barboza is right for the picking.
I think it's fear thinking. Who got knocked out by Gay g? A Barboza did.
He did garb. Kg starched him.
He stepped right to him and pounded his face with the right hand.
And they're doing gay g cowboys. What do you think about that? To fight night.
Okay, so Felder's cut and it looks like he's cut on the forehead.
It was not the fucking switch to the bar. Oh, we checked that one though.
On his left leg. Yeah. That's how you do it. That no, no, no, no, it's not.
We get the body shot. Landis. Was that how you do it? You can.
You certainly can, dude. Look at the look at his fucking ribs now.
But the way he checked it, it was the Shin Slam right into the thick,
heavy part of the bone above the knee or below the knee.
That's where a Chris Weidman broke Anderson Silva's leg. Dude,
that's a disadvantaged home. The skin color like bill burr, anything that hits,
say something. Sandy got headbutted. He said he got head-butted.
He's shaking his head. What does he say? What is he saying? What is he saying?
I think I bring a doctor in here. He was talking that, that's so weird.
What is he saying? It's above it.
So was checking the cut cause coming into his eyes and not really.
That's the fine cut. I don't get it. What's going on?
Let's see what happened. Thank, oh 100% headbutt 100% right there.
So what are they going to say? And they just going to let him play.
But I don't understand why he took that little break. This one to chuck.
I think, uh, wanted to let everybody know that it was a headbutt.
I think herb wanted to check on it to the prop, but he was,
he was motioning to check on that check to say something.
He was alerting herb herb. Oh my God. I'm telling you,
you felt it can land that fucking left man. Well,
Barboza is almost purely a standup when you're almost purely a standup fighter.
It's so, it's Felder and you've had a few knockouts. People, oh,
Barboza is still a purple belt. I don't know. I don't know what is juicy.
It's gotta be a black belt by now. You think so? He's gotta be doing for,
I mean cause even tries to get in the mix for like eight years.
He's threatened with the spin. Ricardo Amido, right. If you look at his hips,
he's looking to spin. You see that right hip. He keeps,
he keeps setting up with his right hip.
Who's got a better wheel kicked in that mother.
He's got the best wheel kick ever against Adam. Remember that?
That was the first ever wheel kit. K on the UFC.
He's at the best switch kick for sure.
I've never seen a switch that for better ever. Never see.
Even in Moitai I've never seen someone with a faster Bishkek and it's also
powerful man.
You ever see when Mark Henry is holding pads for him and he hits that switch
kick, it's like cow rack,
like a baseball bat cow rack. He's feeling good now. He's,
he saw the blood and the fun fight running down Felder's faith.
He's feeling good now.
Felder's in an interesting situation because he's a fucking dangerous guy for
sure. He's a tough fight for anybody but his face is busted.
But Kenny be a world champion, you know,
and if he can't is he going to eventually just step back and just commentate
Ooh. Barboza with a gun. I would imagine if,
let's say you get kicked code in this, I would imagine it goes through his head.
Well I could probably just become dated.
I fish tacos or hurt his leg right there.
I don't like the way he wobbled after Felder checked that kick.
I think Barboza is right legs and a little bit of trouble cause he wobbled and I
don't like how he's moving. Which leg? Just right leg. His right leg. Yup.
He threw a kick and Felder checked it perfectly and Barboza had that little,
Oh fuck I hurt my shin wobble and now he hasn't thrown it and he's moving away
moving Tinder limits or something. Wow.
Look at that month you seasoned movie tie professional fighters.
Can they still get like, like Kit Kayla like no, like,
like can they get their leg kick checked and it hurts? Yes. Still it,
it still hurts. It's still can't get to the point where it doesn't hurt no more.
Cause the nerves are dead. Right. It's always the muscle.
Well there's all tissue around in and trees and there's all this stuff from
banana trees are easy. Dude, I could kick the fuck out of a banana tree.
Tie Fighters will still feel pain in their shin. They called [inaudible].
Most of it, they feel on the outside of the Shin, the bone,
the Shin gets what's called calcified. Right.
So you have these microfractures that are happening all over your Shin as you're
clashing shins and hitting heavy bags and hitting sand bags and all that shit
gets dead. But what doesn't get dead is all this shit around it.
So when you add hot on that shit, yes. All that can to like here,
like this kind of shit here. I always thought,
is there a point where your leg is just like, doesn't feel shit. Well,
your leg meat, leg up here, up top, there's always always vulnerable.
Particularly like our Nesto hoost he used to target right above the knees.
So no matter how much experience you have, if you get hit in the right spot,
yeah, it hurts. Yeah. Especially a guy like who stood God. Yeah.
Like mark poses a leg kick, a Saurus,
he's such a monster with his leg kicks. There's that switch.
Look at that switch. So he's lighting ribs up. He's checking it though.
And every time he checks it Barboza is going to step back because you can snap
your fucking Shin and he's checking
it with his knee pulls Kalief next to yeah, to be honest. Damn,
I can't wait for that fight. What happened? That was two hours quit. Well Shit,
there you go to the body failed it with a kick to the body. So He fell.
It was like one step behind.
I think if you're going to beat Barboza like the way gate she did it,
you got to literally throw yourself into the fire Khabib.
You got to break it down and smash them. Smashed some down.
So did Kevin Lee like you get, you got to wrestle them.
You can't sit here and play this game. If you do sit here and play this game,
you got to do it. The weight gain she does when she goes out,
he runs into the fire. Look, he's made out of his bestest.
He just fucking throws himself into it. He makes it a fucking Bronx.
He makes it a horrible kissing on the outside of the trade.
You can't sit on that. Exactly. Exactly.
So this is a show bar. Bowie.
Now look at this. He wants to steal this round.
Paul's lighten them up with some elbows down there and fellow Felder's a double.
Great. [inaudible] but it doesn't matter.
He's told no when in the round it does matter.
Cause Paul at [inaudible] it doesn't matter if the [inaudible] open him up bad.
It doesn't matter if the round ends now, but it's three minutes to go.
Three 30 to go out. I'm no bad. And when did he cut him from the bottom? Yes,
he's leading. Susan went down their elbow.
Oh Shit we have, we seen Felder play guard.
Oh Ladies and gentlemen.
[inaudible] the actor. Come Sit Down Aka the actor. Where's your wine?
You want some whiskey? Cheese. You want some whiskey? Be One.
A little whiskey. I like plans. Well if you're gonna push me, I'll do.
You're like what? Blands oh,
we still have [inaudible] from acting. I do. Didn't you wipe it off? Looks good.
You should hire someone to do that all day. I have to catch you up dude. I have.
I have a sheen and tight skin dude. Let's go get this hard bar from the bottom.
Fell out. Felder's a bad motherfucker, man. Look at this. This is a blood bath.
It is a blood. A lot of like stuff that just chatter about,
look how bad Barbosa is leaking.
We've got back bottom fucked up man. There you go. Thanks.
You're the best buddy. You push her, but if a pusher, no,
just when you join the fun. Woo. This is a blood bath show.
This is the second round I was at. This is the best fight of the card so far.
It's an amazing mouth behind his fucking here. Yeah, look at that man. Good guy.
Oh right hand Barboza was having a hard time seeing
this is [inaudible].
I remember the bags at the cage side of the first fight and he had such red
welts on his body from Felder's. Looks like such an Allen, doesn't I?
I don't know if this is this thing. You were there for the first fight.
I was there for the first fight.
Was that one that I can't remember but I could hear it go black.
I think it's Vegas. Had to have been Vegas.
It was going to say you wouldn't travel.
How weird is it that all this blood starts when a savage walks in the room?
How weird is that? Oh,
a savage like dean called you walk in and all this blood spills.
What's going on? Oh, the elbow Felder just caught him.
That was a hard shot. Dude. Felt Felder's bat to win this fight.
Third rounds are both getting hot and he's melting.
Oh look at this fell just coming on strong. Yeah.
Why 24 to go higher do work Philly boy. It felt so hard to hurt.
He's so hard to hurt. I mean he was going crazy all over the world right now.
Philly's finest Catalan. Hartford.
Woo White people are calling crazy. Boom. Nice whiskey.
I can't place that nice to best drink again.
It's a good Swiss skates. Like you could drink my goto and I go to a bar. Yup.
Oh, a Felder's. Right. Arm's hurting him.
He ate daddy that cause he went like this with his arm in a stiff way from
[inaudible]. Yeah. And he's trying to hit him with an elbow now. Look guys. Oh,
you're right. He's kind of winged guys hurt. See how it's like hanging by? Yeah,
he ate that switch. Kick on the arm. Dude. Barboza kicked so hard.
If you catch that shit on your triceps, hey,
these two are fucking each other up. Fuck caviar. This is a great fight.
Great Fight Theater Major. For those of you guys wondering. Yeah, brilliant man.
As he is, look at that deep, deep on the shot shot. Nothing. Damn.
People would get twisted that they think Barboza has horrible take on the fence.
He just fights fucking months.
Do you think those guys and the white get mad at bla gets on them? Like I say,
there's Tom and Cruz domino. I bet they like a little color. Oh,
the guys back there. The Saudis? Yeah, the princes. Are they princes?
If they're wearing that now,
but that these are granted or some money in that group right there.
I just assume they're all princes, but there's a,
there's a hundred princes then. Yeah.
Is there a hundred places for a guy to be a prince? Oh, they're in Saudi Arabia.
This is all no Abudabi come on Bro. My second round,
I assume they're all princes. They all drive lambos bro.
Barboza probably dusted and half toilet. Hey, Barboza is with att.
When did that, when did that switch take place? Oh, that's right.
He went to Florida. He moved back down to Florida to become a [inaudible]. No,
I think he was his family. I think he wanted to be a,
I think his family's down there.
I think he'd had to do with something about also being able to travel back and
forth easily to Brazil. Who is the guy in his corner? The guy with the tattoos.
What's his name? Great take downs or Marcos Demato I think necessarily as, yeah.
Per romper. Nah, that's not the good one. How do you say that? [inaudible] oh,
Ooh. That hug. Look at that Hook. Oh God damn it.
You can't get here we go round three and he had a piss.
Don't go piss me right here. Run, run. Get three pounds. The experts here.
That's right, buddy. Duke, Rufus Scape Kiss. You don't laugh.
He's an expert asshole. Thank you God. So rude. I know.
He's really silly. Brendan. Sorry. I come from the set guy.
Sorry about my makeup and I'm feeling a little emotional.
Are you emotional because you've been acting? Do you train? Do you Dang.
I'm so drained, right? Recite one line. Did you? No, no, no.
You have to watch the show, sir.
Scheduled Wednesday nights at eight 30 let's wait until after the round then you
could do is set. Boom. Kicked it. The Baal Barboza looks tired,
man. In between rounds. He looked very tired. They still throw him big balls.
Yeah, he's got some, he's still got snapped. Those Brian.
Apparently this is a new arena and it's hot as hell.
They're saying that it's more than 120 degrees inside the arena or feels like
it's 120 degrees. Dry Heat, dry heat,
but still very commentated for pride in 2000 in the year 2000 and we were in
like some Tokyo stadium and it was so fucking hot and humid.
I had a suit with a coat.
I wouldn't take the jacket off because I was completely drenched on the inside.
Dude, you gotta take a jam. I'm like, dude,
you don't want to see what's under this. How was it looked like?
I jumped in a pole. It was so hot. Pride. 10 pride.
10 did you watch all those fights? It was like 110 degrees.
Pure humidity. It was death. Go back and watch those fights. That was when I,
Hanzo and Sakharova went at it. Rumor that Shit. Yes I do. Yes.
Felder just called them. The legend goes in Saudi Arabia and Bahrain,
places like this.
It certain times of the year you can fry an egg on the pavement if it's been out
there. Felder pressing the pace here. I wonder who's winning this fight.
You know we've been talking but I mean you've been talking. What about you bro?
I've been watching paying attention, bro.
I'm a fight kind of sore. Yes you are dude.
And I didn't know you were that tatted out. Well,
I'm good at talking with your shoulders watching like I do that. Yes,
your watch and talk to it for a living sometimes I wouldn't say a living.
It's like a side job now where you were going to this fight.
Hundreds couldn't get to you though.
I'm not interested in getting all the way over there when I can do this with you
guys. Right.
And be like super close to home and do sets last night at the store.
Imagine when the fights over spinning back fist by,
by both sides that that might've been a wheel that was real.
Flight's gonna suck that. Not that he should show.
He started the same thing with a wheel kick.
I bet you catch the flight sucks and it sucks getting there and it sucks when
your body is so fused. Oh my God,
these guys are colliding two 47 ago. Who?
Who's winning the first [inaudible] clipped him with some shots at the shore.
Oh, what if Dennis said, okay,
we'll fly you to Abu Dhabi private jacket with a king size bed.
It's not good enough.
The problem is it does your body in and it still takes 16 hours.
Kingsize fucking bed. I don't know. I got one of those at home, Bro.
Some fighters can take just full shot, full back kicks and just keep coming.
These two guys are made of metal. Well, it depends on how it lands,
man who's throwing it, but it doesn't matter who you are. Feelings correctly.
You ain't come for, yeah. That's one of those kicks. It's just, it just,
there's just a lot. It's not designed to take that. No matter who you are,
your left hand,
you don't get get in better shape than that fell to hurt him with that left
counter. Oh he did. He hit him with a right hand too. Well, that time.
Diff elder coming on strong, man. I fell down tiny. That left hooks.
I'm in the middle of filter. Felder's pushing it here. God fell.
There's a beast. They better give this fight to Felder just cause, well,
who knows? There's two rounds of blood coming off of Barboza.
Barboza it's gotta be filled up with the,
he's finishing strong, dude. I, I would give to filter such a warrior
base pants off. Take your pants. I know. Based on white privilege.
I'll give it to the elder to meadows, to meadows. 10 minutes.
Tell me that him and Chris Barley, him and Chris Farley used to play this.
They do this bit where it'd be Chris Beck.
They pretended they were detectives and Chris [inaudible]. Oh Man.
What do you think happened in Chris' father? Go take your pants off.
Let me fuck your ass. Why? And he goes,
cause this is how we're going to figure out what happened.
So it was that stupid so stupid.
Reminds me getting pumped really fucked up thing that we did.
Oh that was the best you got to play. Oh
so good.
Come on Bro. It's so fun. Realize that to you games you saying. And I was like,
so rounding muscles, I got to do squats. I got it. Flat Ass. And she says,
well you got a great ass dude.
It's all round and muscular. Take your pants off. Do you guys know that during,
you know when you guys start fucking during that bit we'd like
right when I used to DJ at a Strip Club at strip clubs, dude, that was uh,
w we had to uh, there was a part, there was a song by enigma,
there was a super sexy spiritual atmospheric. So don't let it take you down.
Don't let us take you down. Stand up. You've got to, let me think.
Does that count? Hold on. It's not good for the judges though, what happened?
But when I'm,
when I'm at the Strip club and I'm playing this enigma song, right,
and there's this, it's like a meal cooler, but very popular enigma song.
It's like spiritual and there's all these Gregorian chants and it's so spiritual
and sexy and then the music drops out and it's silent and you hear a girl go,
ah, just for two seconds. Every time I got to that part,
every time it never failed.
I'd always mix in you fucking Bryan calendar in the ass.
So there's the girl going
and the strippers hated that I did that. You don't do that.
But the manager loved it so much he would tell them to,
but you shut the fuck up. Go do some lap dances. I get it.
So every time I'd mix in you to fucking with a N***a above me,
a corner where I'm really fucking, by the way, fake
you guys. How was that? Was that I was drunk. I don't remember. What was that?
I needed the money. What was that for? An album that I had,
I did an album on Warner brothers in 99 back in the does a Oh,
hold on 20 years ago. How many specials do you have Joe? Including numbers.
One, two, three,
four, five,
six, seven fuck a nine.
Yeah. Nine, nine specials. Jesus. When are you gonna drop the next? I Dunno man.
No rush.
[inaudible] by 2020 21 I have a legit hour right now. You know,
I'm doing the big these big arenas and shit and it's all great. I'm loving it.
I'm having fun and I'm just, uh, enjoying work on my act. Like, yeah.
Instead of saying, oh, I got to do an hour or special within, you know, like,
it's been almost one year since my last special dropped.
Did it be one year in October?
And so I think I'm gonna wait another year before I even think about it.
Do this. Tighten everything up. Yeah. Shit's ripping already though. Yeah.
Everything's great man. But when I was talking to Jessalyn neck,
I was talking to Jellinek about specialists. An interesting story.
He's a monster and he had a great take colors.
Try tell her want it. Talk about putting it all on the line,
man. Fuck yes. How happy he is. Fuck yeah. We're also happy for him. Everybody.
Yeah, I'm a taxed him. Wow. You know what man? I mean, he's had some hard times,
man. The Mike Perry fight was rough. Broke his arm early, hung in there. I mean,
this is so cool too because Anna can Feld her. Love each other. It's great.
Oh they do? Oh, they're good flies. Hope we've done commentary together.
Oh true. John. Anik is one of the nicest fucking guys. A lie. Fucking love.
I'm never gonna find a single person who knows and has a bad word to say.
Randomly text them about once a month. Yeah, he's a big better.
Oh yeah, he is. He is
[inaudible]
I still grind. Does he not look like Stephen King? Am I crazy?
No, you're crazy. That's an easy off loss. Well listen man,
Barboza is, you know,
he's had some good ones and bad ones and always watched Barboza fight.
He's a great fighter man. And again, his switch kick is the fucking,
that's the benchmark for everybody. Look at him. So happy.
So Felder, oh shit. Felder one
with 29 28 damn. Fuck yeah, I just sent him a text, man.
I love that guy. He's such a good dude.
Hold on. [inaudible].
Yeah, I'm in here. Get some look at him.
I don't know [inaudible]
I'm so happy for him. He's right there, you know?
And he's right there in the mix now. But you hear me just said an actor.
Let's get him a job. He said otherwise I'll get top five. I'm retired.
I'm an analyst. I can be an actor. Yeah, I'll be on come, come get a come,
go get schools
to slow down redhead with the whole acting thing. Chill out.
It's not the answer is or acting. Acting. Tina's got all your parts. Yeah.
It's got all your fun guy. Pretty good. Got the other ones.
The guy that's Dion's.
I don't know the full it felt there might not a real red head though.
He's a red beard.
He doesn't count like Tina is a real red right here on the top of his head.
It's a brown. How crazy is that? It's almost like he dies his beard red.
It's pretty cool. More of a Celt is an animal though. Yeah. He,
Tina's a real red head with red head aggression. He's got everything.
All redheads are freckles. Are they? He's an Italian redhead,
but they're all spicy now. He's a fire up. He's a fire crows rocket.
Is He half red? I mean half Italian. Half hours. Half. It's gotta be half.
He's a funny motherfucker. Yeah, you sent Tino.
I love going on the road with him too. He's such a good guy. I love Santina.
Yeah, I love you guys. You coming into Detroit or Minneapolis? No.
Is that it? No, Detroit and Cleveland. Detroit and Cleveland.
Santina is coming with me. He helped me. He opened up it. Just
hilarious. Now he's an animal. Good fucking dude too. He's just funny. Solid,
solid little bit of a boozer. Well, he has a podcast.
The whiskey ginger with God said, I heard, I heard.
I shouldn't say hi Brian. You're in time.
You're perfectly in time because you may have made event, dude. Right?
You didn't come with cheese and there's no Aoki pizza, but whatever. That hurts.
Forgive both of you. I was already so late. I was rushing to,
didn't even open until noon. I was like, oh, come on Steve. I would take,
so he has a pizza chit load of them. He's got his, yeah.
Steve Aoki is a business. My Love. Stevia. Okay.
He's a great pizza's not on the wet. No, I thought it was.
We can get some afterwards and the Eddie's better than anybody in this fucking
room. Isn't that cool? Look at his skin. His skin is flawless.
It actually works. Skin is not flawless. Dude,
my dude come here and look up the mirror going, oh my God,
now you have good skin, dude. Fucking almost 60 now you're not.
You know what I mean? The hollers, how old are you? I'm old. I'm 50 next year.
You look book I every day I'm like, it's over. You have makeup on.
It's better skin. I now like my life is for my son. Like I like my life is over.
It's all about what your life is. You're alive. Stop saying that.
You got to keep. I think that, I think it's all about my son will listen.
It's great that you think like that, but you're alive and you're looking great.
Thank you. I appreciate that. I like your hair. Thank you.
You look the youngest out of the four of us. Yeah, you do. How old are you?
Well, no, Brendan. Dude, you're a baby
diaper baby dude. Not really dirty.
Get my white hat. Ain't shit, dude. He's 35.
You've got a comedy career now like at 40.
Started comedy again. I don't, I don't know how the fuck you're,
you're funny man. I'm doing seminar.
Last time I saw you last time I saw you at the store,
you made me laugh hard. I laughed a bunch of times. Thank you.
The story about you getting laid for the first time,
that is a fucking hilarious story. Did you try it before Eddie? Before this? No,
I did. I did some like before 10th Planet Jujitsu. It was even a thought. Uh,
I was hanging out with Joe at the comedy store every goddamn weekend he was in
town and if he wasn't in town and he was on the road,
I'm like hanging out with Joe.
So I was balls deep in the comedy scene and I did some, uh,
open mics a little bit here and there. But I realized back then that, uh,
standup comedy was like a martial art.
It's like you have to spend a lot of time on stage getting good at times,
being on the public speaking experience and the public speaking skills,
that's the most important thing.
You don't even have to be fucking funny to be a successful comic.
You decide to be confident on stage and have public speaking
[inaudible] funny. Did you know what I'm saying? But listen,
that's just because they're famous. Yeah. They're famous at other things.
My point,
my point is that public speaking experience and those skills are crucial and I
didn't have them back then. I was, I was horrible at public speaking experience.
Why are they showing it? Yeah. Why do they want to show that bra?
How are they highlighting this? He came out to tell him, dad, they do well,
Dylan Dennis was talk shit dude. Did you take Kebab in the interview? Bret Modo?
No. He goes, oh, it's not over. He goes, you know, everyone wants to say, oh,
it's a, it's for the fight. He goes, not for me. I see him,
which were basically fucking them up. He goes, it will never be over.
And he goes, look guys, well that's what he said. He goes, he goes, people,
you know, because they, it's a, it's a sport and we fight in the cage. He goes,
it's bigger than it. Never be over. And then when we fight,
Conor McGregor was absolutely not, never happened. He was.
But if I see him outside of it, we'll fight. Whoa.
And you know how certain guys hype things up? He's in his fucking boxers in his,
uh, you know, in his hotel room and he just dead serious like Jesus.
That's why he's so good.
Who the fuck is as good as could be when you're looking at a guy who's like,
what is he 28 and Oh, I mean, what is cribs record 27, 28,
27, 28, 28 and 28, 28 and now fought the best in the world.
Mauled everyone and what he did when he would, what he did is like,
just like you see right now it's being publicized and so it's like,
it's not going to deter him from doing it again. No. You know what I mean?
They're just showing the shit out of it right now. Well, you know,
we'll Harris from will Harris productions is the one who filmed Connor throwing
that Dolly at the, uh, at the bus and the UFC asked for it and he was like,
yeah, yeah. You could look at the footage,
but thought he was going to get credit. They didn't get any credit.
Like will Harris Anatomy of a fighter? It's a fucking phenomenal.
Youtube could do too. Great Guy. I met him on the podcast.
He goes over to Abu Dhabi,
he goes over to Dagestan and hangs out with those guys. He'd get solid dude.
He gets the best footage. She has the best footage, fight footage,
training footage like inside behind the scenes footage of anybody.
And he never thought he like y'all let the,
cause he thought they would show it as like a news piece. Meanwhile,
every fucking promo for the fight was that Dali that we'll film getting thrown
at the bus. Like TMZ would've paid $2 million for that. Right.
The worst shit that Connor did was the thing that they use to sell the fight.
Literally a felony. I mean, he's like, people got got hung from the gun,
like a glass and Chase's eyes let him buildings in this building.
I gotta tell you right now, I'm going to say something right now.
I believe it can be general. I believe that, excuse me, very [inaudible].
These guys, real time guys from a Russian republic, but now it's an independent,
genuine match, tattoos and they're on there. You know what, they're athletes.
No, I'm, I'm going to say this and the job is the most of my money.
I got my money on Dustin Poirier. Whoa,
how much money I kind of do till this and let's see if we can move the money
around here because that was credited and he goes, Brendan,
$20 and he's never going to pay some. Maybe eventually,
eventually I'll pay maybe two tickets Brendan, and if it's a wash,
if you win you'll, you'll let Eddie off the hook. I just think that,
I just think that if, if Khabib tries to trade with Dustin,
Dustin is cube could be doing best strikers. Period. Oh boy. Listen.
He proved that in the Max Holloway final question and he's got real power,
hard real power and Justin Gay chief, but also the other [inaudible] brands.
Fine.
The other thing why I like a a little bit in this as a dog is because if you
watch a Justin [inaudible] fight where Katie's just applying pressure, pressure,
pressure. Dustin really doesn't fate. He plays that game.
Nobody has taken Dustin down,
mauled them on the ground and that is the difference.
Question is going to be whether or not it could be, you can take it.
Here's my question taking them. How did I acquainted?
Keep Cubby from taking him down. How did he do it? They didn't. Could be,
definitely took him down,
but I acquainted as a back whose backgrounds as a wrestler, he said, look,
I escape but I, but gates, he never like, first of all, Kate,
she never fought Khabib and gate g I'm saying with Tufts doesn't try to take
guys down even though he's a wrestler,
he's also fucking 100% savage and that guy just throws himself into the fog.
But with, you know, a lot of people think he's definitely wild,
but it's a controlled wildness. It's intelligent. Wildlands so here we go.
Champion versus champion.
I think the UFC has to be very careful with this whole interim champion stuff
because they take them away from people like Colby, like this.
There's talk right now of Colby not getting the fight versus Uzman and Colby
says they're not offering them enough money and it's going to be in New York
state.
And apparently there's a lot of taxes that come with fighting in New York.
Same with Tony. Tony's even more. Well,
they're both agregious cause Tony got injured in doing promo. Right.
Accidentally. Not his fault. They strip him.
I liked the way he's running toward the fucking cage. Sorry to interrupt.
You keep going. Well a lot of guys do these two experiments to let this moment
over shy. He's nice and he's, you know,
on paper could be does definitely gonna win on paper but could be,
it's never lost around in passing. And Josh just gonna fucking Mazda doll.
Astron don't forget about that. Don't forget about that shit.
That shit could happen. One, he said 100% different,
but I had Mazda Dalton. I saw Mazda Dog's going to win that fight.
I'll fight for Ben regardless. Flying me.
I thought I was going to get in the same dimension. What'd you say?
Aspirin and Capybara and the same dementia.
They take people down and they maul them. No, but once a freestyle wrestler,
one guy's a son, but it's a little different. Okay. Okay.
I see what you're saying or what you're saying on paper,
but I think the differences could be has way better striking than Ben,
but it could be, he was also not a freestyle, you know,
double leg shoot from far out, like also smashes people,
punches and drops con and wants an under hood.
Underestimate Mazda dolls set up. Oh yeah. Oh No, it's great.
And then the plan was to run at them and throw a fly on me.
How do you set that up? You set it up with doing the opposite. What did he do?
He put his hands behind his back. Chill, lean against the fence.
He did the opposite. A fucking mind. Fuck.
Ask Ren and then boom, he bolted at them and through that,
hold on. I'm not just bolted first. He stepped in front of the ring first.
He went to his right.
The ideas until [inaudible] set up and then he comes into the opposite.
Do the opposite of what he wanted to do. Right? That's fight IQ.
Mazda dos is high a fight. IQ is anybody in the game to doubt?
Put that in a fucking movie. But then in a movie he's happy to be.
I was the executive producer. I would show my shit.
This is a life's work like that. Guys. Don't talk over Eddie.
This is a life's work days waiting for this moment.
He was creaming in his pants right now at home. I mean he's, he's,
he is literally happy to be here. That's a huge sign of me. Wow.
How could he not be? He's getting paid. Well,
he should say pussy. Hey, he's getting paid.
He's got Mike Brown in his corner. I don't, I don't, when this one piece,
if I say pussy, if you went this one who get paid? Who's that? Oh,
I go with don. My railroad style. Jose.
Here comes Colby. Man. It comes. Could be, boy. I would like to hear it. Jamie,
can we give us some volumes so we hear how crazy everybody goes. Nuts.
This is bigger reading taken off. They're smaller. It's not a big reason at all.
That is true. Like 16,000 capacity.
I think three should have the possibility to do whatever the fuck you want to do
with the UFC. Yeah, you should be. Youtube doesn't play that I get to as fuck.
I get you. I'll get, I've had my shit taken down off of Facebook.
I've had my shit taken down off the Instagram.
Has this for posting ever while you worked for the FC sat you down and say you
can't do this or that. Never.
No one's ever talked to companion show where they maybe chill out on no,
they love it.
Dana wants me to do a companion for Tuesday night contender series. So like,
he's like, mom, you do one for those. I'm like, maybe we will one night.
You know for fun, if we're, we're around, I'm down for that.
Let's do some great fights.
I do one for winter series and a lot of those guys eventually become like legit
contenders. I'll, there's some really good guys cas. Yeah, we should do that.
We should do a Tuesday night contender series. Fight companions for boxing. No,
UFC. UFC has a fight. Pat, you don't know any of them. Fucking suck.
My testosterone spike dude and my head never started. [inaudible] good luck.
Good luck finding my head to protect in the ass from that May.
I had never stopped fucking Eddie bet. Did you and Eddie bet on this fight?
Yeah. Huh? I got $100 on this fight.
Dan hundred betting on Dustin's a friend of mine. Guys, I'll through.
I'll throw the money in just for a goof.
I'll throw a hundred [inaudible] on the, on the Russian. He's got his,
he's got his dad. I want to see your money. I got, I got the Honda.
I got it right here. Well, let's put it on the table. It's sitting right here,
dude. He's wiping off his armpits. I use mine. Listen, this is not that.
I don't love Dustin Poray but I do love action. I love,
actually let myself look at me. Actor. Hold on. How much cash do I pay?
Cash. Oh, here you go. Here's a hundred k right there. Oh Wow. Your money down.
Okay. Your boys run low on cash. What the fuck I did.
I was going gonna back you, but I spent last night. Alright, it's okay.
I lend them the money. I'm gambling answer myself.
This is good because this way I'm basically either giving Brian money or not.
So it's not like a gambling against Dustin who I love.
Khabib is looking rather rather jack more than usual in my opinion. Nope.
That's what he looks like. Always looks like. Create a little drama. I'm sorry.
The big thing, the big thing is his father in his corner in the back.
To me that's the game changer, right? Because his father can't come to the UFC.
Here's the females cause you can't get a visa. But,
and here's the other thing is Khabib will listen to his father. He, if you,
if you watch the uh, the I Quinta fight when Javier is telling them what to do,
he's just like, yeah, whatever dude. And does his thing. His Dad talks,
he listens. So if his dad goes, hey bitch, quit fucking tone. Enhance,
take him down. He's gonna take him down. Yeah. Here he goes.
I'll be this bad mother fucker. That crap must be going crazy right now. I mean,
even thinking about how many people are Muslim in the world,
this guy is the guy.
He might be the most popular Muslim athlete on Earth. I think Internet is,
he's probably the most famous, right? UFC fighter. Like the International.
How many millions of followers does he have on Instagram too? That's good.
Oh No, no, no, no. He's like 26 million. No Way. How many is he?
26 something crazy. Jamie is going to find out, let's say seven.
I'm going to say 10 16 million. That's a lot.
You understand where he got in the show? 16 million.
But you understand that before he fought Connor, he had like one, not even one.
How many does Connor have? 30 does he have Beyonce?
I looked at Justin Bieber the other day. Had like 118 million. I'm like
[inaudible] uh,
Trump 30 to go? No.
Selena Gomez is the [inaudible] 32 50 Gomez.
Khabib is a way bigger star than Connor.
Khabib comes Dagestan is where like the Mirage goes to Turks. It's just this,
the Ottomans that everybody converge [inaudible] as 156 million.
She's number one. And it could be, but 16 million and Connor had
31.7 he's got more Comez. Connor's got doubled. Connor's accomplished.
She that big.
Connor's a soupcon hunters like celebrity [inaudible] and beyond saying no way.
Do you think that a lot of those are fake?
Do you think that Selena Gomez ones are fake? Are they little kids?
They're kids though. That's why people, kids and girls have the most followers.
I have no idea. I don't know one Selena Gomez Song. Do you,
do you know one song? No.
Am I the ones that go to bed to and wake up to one name? One? No, can't name.
I can sing them beyond sack and name a couple. Well, this fuck Eddie. Yeah.
Yeah. We just talked about how old we are. That's a Destiny's child song.
Okay. Maybe I don't know any fiance. Yeah, right.
Marshawn Arenado actually has 182 million. Who Does? Cristiana Rinaldo. Oh yeah.
That was a soccer player. They are the best of her novel. Ms Cristiana.
Rinaldo messy and how much mercy on it sounds like a girl. Christiana.
102 for messy. Again,
Ronaldo's like a celebrity dates hot chicks, and they're looking at him tots.
MSCI has 130 Jesus Christ. How many? How many does Lebron have?
14 no, this at 50. 60 rocks.
1461 56 for the rock has one 56. The one that,
whew. Instagram account is 312 million, but
[inaudible] Instagram, no one ever account. No one does Twitter.
No know who's their account? The Instagram account. Instagram,
their own account. That didn't count already on the ground.
363 for Ariana Grande Day. Wow.
Whew. Count. What do you got? 700,000. That's good. Keep it low. Keep it low.
Stand on the radar. It's funny how that's low now. I was like, I know.
Used to be a big deal. Right? You remember when, um, when asked him,
she was in a competition with somebody to see who hit a million Twitter
followers? No, that was a while ago. Big Deal. Oh, CNN,
CNN and Ashton Kutcher walking around competition to see who it's a million and
these guys get down to 50 [inaudible] so [inaudible] trying to up to 200.
Luke Rockhold. Tommy,
he's like probably walking around at 200 pounds now while he's training. Yeah,
he's eating bad. Is he eating everything that moves? He's definitely thick,
but he's never, he's not 200. Not Lean. When he's, when he's at 200,
I think of that has got us to close right there. Here we go, baby.
Here we go. Whew. Boy It looks, everyone looks sweaty.
Super Shiny.
It's hard as fuck in there. Bad.
[inaudible] let's go around the table. Eddie Bravo. What's up on paper?
Cubby takes this, uh, I hope he wins only because, uh,
it would make it like a monstrous fight between him and Tony.
But you can't count Dustin out. You know, he could throw a flying knee,
but you gotta catch him. If I had a gun to the head,
that gun to the head, I'd go. Could be, that's the safe.
But I'm not going to be surprised if Dustin drops him.
I'm gonna say pour a third round Kale and then fights Conor McGregor.
Ah, fights McGregor. Wow. Cowen.
We think I'm going, I love cubby. Um,
I think portray drops him in one round. Dude,
I'm in the fourth round type move and I think, uh,
and I think he's going to fight Conor McGregor. Wow.
Okay. Well you just said exactly how do those reshoots go? Brian Do,
do those reshoots shoot, I'm glad you're asking me what were the lines? No, no.
Fuck those lines. Here we go. We're about to do this. Yeah. Please
note how I've cleverly avoided making a prediction. Let's move on.
You can't make predict. You have to. Here we go. Here we go. Oh Shit.
Oh Shit. Nope. Nope.
Nothing interesting about Dustin is Dustin South Pole with a fucking nasty
straight left hand. Yep. And great combos. Although he did fight Connor,
who was also south Paul. Oh, that's a while ago. It's got much longer. Arms.
Got better kicks. Dustan also has hip issues.
He said some pretty significant wear and tear on his hip. He's fine.
He's a black belt on the ground, but I don't think can be, gives a flying fuck.
Dozens of black belts caught that leg under Tim crater.
I believe his training partners were guys like, you know, Robbie Lawler,
et Cetera, before a lot will Robby went left a ATG notice right away.
Staying on the outside could be was avoiding the kicks.
He's staying away from Dustin.
Striking length cause death and striking lights is a boxing length.
So Dustin's forced to throw kicks, which he doesn't necessarily prefer.
So when he's throwing those kicks,
could bebes caught a couple of them already or caught one of them at least,
but he's avoided the kicks. But see the distance, look at the distance,
sees Khabib is staying outside the striking range and looking for that opening
for the shot. C C Dustin's forced to throw kicks, but he's not a kicker.
That's not as shit, especially with a bad hip. And so could be,
oh here's the shot,
here's the Dustin's no punk with his take down defense man.
But he's never seen anybody like could be never fought anybody.
That's that good. But here he goes. But the other thing is,
it's keeping [inaudible] even if could be, doesn't take you down. The draining.
He drained. It does this a lot of energy for condense and
tired though. Really, really by Quinta. Conor McGregor flights.
He takes rounds up striking me. Yeah, but
[inaudible] knows the mauling begins the mauling now he's standing up or goes
up. Not Quiet. Not Quiet. He's not up yet. Boom. No.
Dustin's going to get taken down into the ground. It's a switch.
Nope, no, on his bathroom. Now it's around. Not Good.
I might be over very bad. Very, very, very bad. First rounds.
Very bad for Dustin. Very bad. He might get smashed here. Oh look. Yeah,
he pulls his face like that. He actually got fingers on his eyes, man.
I can't tell like I got bears that $100. That's my $100 you know,
it's crazy. You know what's crazy is that, oh my God, it's over.
It's over. He's going to use that full cart track is going to use that footage.
Oh No. That was close to being over
someone. Here's a Jujitsu coach. Oh,
big shots is this where it doesn't want to be sideways,
like not where he wants to be, but sideways. And this time. No, he's fun.
He's in a good spot right down right here because he tells your grades face,
man, look,
he's actually using the cage to defend the rear naked choke cause he's got the,
he doesn't have the angles. See how he's sideways? He's using that cage.
It's covering his mouth. It's so cool.
Shout just couldn't have been gun any worse for justice. Might be. It might be.
It might be it. Dustin's trying. He's trying to survive, man.
He's trying to survive more people have an adopted, oh,
he's got a nasty no crank here. Oh, Dustin survives. Doesn't survive.
Oh, standing. Standing, standing.
Whoa. Don't count him out. Damn those so close.
He just asked for the money back. You fuck. I don't remember that.
You're off the train. I don't have any. Oh,
he's going to have to turn like that. Why don't you do that?
I don't know why he did that. He just tried to separate the hands.
That's why he's trying to separate the hands. Never turn your back on.
I think he's just trying to separate the hands. All right. Okay.
You just tried to face their guns. Let's fucking go. Come on. Just just be cool.
He might just try to wear this out or ride this out. Rather,
he's going to survive to the second round for sure. Who the fuck knows for sure?
Some minute to go, man. Anything can happen. It's going to take. There you go.
Oh, that trip coming up. Do you just keep standing up?
You know he's gonna get slammed right now. He is. He both way. He controls this.
There's no one better, man. He's the best. He's a mall or bursts.
The best smaller man fucking wrestles with.
Oh, it's not going to work. His hands were close,
which is not gonna work on your hands and competes too good.
It's not going to work. Now he's mounted, man. Now he's mounted. This
is no boy in only 20 seconds. He's what? No Bueno. No, he's good.
Connor chilled here in the mouth, remember? Yeah, but listen, this is,
we really don't do work. This is a different fight. It's entirely possible.
Con could be, you could get him here. Be Tough. Look at this. We did this. Boom,
boom, boom. Oh, she's ain't good. This ain't good. So how much time,
this ain't good. 10 seconds. Five, four, three two.
That was the rush. A C to survive. Yeah, he survived.
He's fine. Not a mark on know this is going to happen in [inaudible] third,
fourth round man. Yup.
If he can make a third, fourth round. It's crazy. That was crazy.
We got to get some food after this. Yeah, let's get food after this.
We'll go get some fucking monster. But that's that.
You got to walk through the fire to get to that third, fourth round man. Yes.
Yes. So you've got to hope he gets tired from whooping your ass. He's done.
He's done that third and fourth round. He was telling Barbosa to come on, man.
No, he's a different animal. Barbara. Yeah. Oh boy. I'm going to give up.
But they, but they not good. Doesn't know this. He listened.
He is fucking how many fights? 40 fights.
He knows this has been the game for so long, man. Yeah, he's been down.
He's been up. He knows how to lose. He's gonna get a freak out.
He's lost before and bounce back is that shit in his pants, right?
He's a fucking full veteran. He's a full veteran. He's fine. Come in. He's like,
he's not a guy that's going to get broken at this stage of his life.
Beating Kippy even in front of his dad though I have the odds are not good in
front of Russia, sir. In front of Russia and in Abu Dhabi,
it's got Darby shot aside. What I'm saying is that the Russians Watch,
here we go. Here we go. Is watching. Here we go.
Well now you know Dustin's going to want to avoid going to the ground at all
costs lower stance now and then avoiding the distance.
He's still with those kicks, man. I think you waits for Khabib to come in.
I would say avoid those kicks and just wait.
Oh Jesus. Okay. That, oh he got, he got clipped.
[inaudible] Khabib is a striking,
not terrible and just show worried about the take down.
Remember when he dropped Connor? Yeah. Oh, hold on, please.
Dropped other guys too. It's like,
oh,
oh shit.
[inaudible] yeah, but he can, he can't get crazy.
He's wearing them out.
He can't get crazy because he'll run into a takedown. Oh,
she has to play in trouble with them again. Yeah.
It could be my be in trouble here. Oh, dark shit. [inaudible] Dustin's tired.
Dustin's tired. Yes he is. Yes. He retired. He, he's tired.
He just chased him for a minute. Straight dude.
Just took a deep breath or maybe, oh there's a shot.
Oh that's a teen attempt. Oh I've got ideas is bad. It's also,
he was bad with a hundred and fucking 20 degree index inside Alaina.
He got so tired like that. Something happened. Damn.
Duly shout him right there. What do mean something happened?
He just know put his energy out there trying to finish him cause it hurt him a
little bit. Well he got real wild. He got real wild. It doesn't ask it well.
He has to around that. Now this is a big,
if he can [inaudible] 22nd early in the second round.
Why does he have to get wild when when you clip someone. Right.
But he clipped him and hurt him. He could just do that again.
He could just stay technical and keep it on the outside,
which where I think he has an advantage.
I don't think his wildness was the result of this takedown exhaustion,
but the wildness leads to you being exhausted, but they're bo o exhaust.
They're both again. Yes. Cause both times big punches,
exhaust [inaudible] ties, but but could be.
I'm way more efficient at doing this. Yes. He clips your fucking legs.
He crosses your legs. I got crossing. No, no one's figured it out.
Discounts Cross your legs like that. I don't know. Is that a move on camp?
Did you go to, is that like a merit badge? I want to talk about it.
When I was younger I was dressed up like a girl.
It's how I got myself through college. All right. All right. Here we go.
It's going to be two minutes and 30 seconds of this.
Most of the time Dustin just has to kind of hopefully capitalize on those little
moments. By the way, kind of refined here. He's kind of resting,
survives here and then tries to get him, they're both out of bed on the floor.
He just got to survive. Sydney one's case, I've got another shot.
It's really dependent upon what kind of recovery he can have,
how he's dealing with the heat and how, what kind of, Oh God.
He gave his back up again.
He's going to stand up and then use and then like he's bleeding on his left
side. He's relaxed. He's relaxing. That's a bad kid.
This isn't a place to relax though.
It could be [inaudible] going to get back into Sisco.
Face him or he's going to get that left under hook and he's fine.
All you gotta do is just pull that left under, hook out and it's good.
Pull that left. Oh, you didn't get it. He had, he just hurt treasures. No,
don't go. Y'All team back. There you go. Under hooks.
That pressure, that pressure. Dude could.
You've got serious head pressures and the best for,
forget about Bose head pressure and the way he dips his body down and gives us
all the Hayden deep dude. He's on his flight. His head belongs on Brock Lesnar,
by the way, for cubby. He's got the biggest head up to his feet. Oh,
don't grab it. Who is he going to do? Maybe Granby roll.
I'll just going to just keep getting up. It's just killed time.
There's a minute just killed.
This is just killing time for Dustin for another shot to get hope on smart other
shots. Smart. Another shot. Your best bet. SMART, smart. Just drive frustrate.
Don't go. Don't, it's frustrating. Take your stand up. Well,
he doesn't have a neck, dude. There's no way he's going to kill it. No,
you're wishing. Imagine if he did. Only way he could kill it.
Tina is if Dustin is known for a hellacious guillotine and lots of shit that I
be, he's got a hellacious. Doris is Darcy's franchise. Good. I'm liking this,
right. Oh, oh. Oh Damn. Damn right.
Shot shot to separate. He, he was not gonna fuck with it, man.
Didn't give you any breath. He can't dude. He should've just ran. At that point.
Riley ran [inaudible] hit him in the knee,
like patch over new side that went over and ran.
As soon as the separation was run. Look at this up again up again.
Look at this. Oh trip. Beautiful trip. 19 not enough time. He's good.
1716 I'm telling you, Dustin's not taking a lot of damage.
He might be tired, but he's not taking as much damage as he could. Ah, yeah.
Yeah. Aren't you an actor? He got hit with a big knee there, man.
Dustin did oh shit on their feet.
Two rounds of fury. Look at this. God Damn, he's tired for sure.
Of course he tired. Of course.
Sleep suit and fourth round is usually a tough time for him.
I'll say this though.
It's kind of impressive what Connor did come back of that long lift cause we see
what he's doing to Dustin, just to everybody he's about to stand for.
We're Kinda, you know, he did defend a few take downs.
You know what I am landing some shot. I see Dustin like,
like this is the game plan where I'm out a hundred percent hundred percent,
the sort of, I survived. Serve Austin's a hundred percent dangerous.
He's in the mix, right? He can knock you out.
I would love to be listening to a Mike Brown's coaching say to, you know what?
If he takes you down, just survives. I love Mike [inaudible].
He shot lots of shots. Oh shit man,
that was legit and then shit. Oh No,
look at that. He's still, he heard him. He heard him. Oh Shit.
And then the shot, man, he screws up.
The thing is you go looking for that shot up.
You gotta go for the Servant of looking for those shots.
You gotta be real conservative, calm. Champlin you wanna win. You wanna win.
You've got to get wild. He's gotta to just look at every go. Here we go.
Every beginning of every round is the time to knock them out.
And once you get shot on, okay, just survived two chains in the crowd.
How the fuck did that happen to changes there?
It looked like is how do you know what two chains looks like?
I don't know what's to check. What is that? What'd you say?
Jamie's sit next to Dana. Is He to James's? What is to chain? He's a rapper.
Oh really? He debated Nancy grace about marijuana.
He hasn't been hot for a second, but maybe he's hot goes why?
He looks, he looks tired. He's certainly tired. Yeah. You know,
he certainly tired. He's looking for like, oh, no problem man. This is it.
Oh, dusty. Oh No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
That is Huggies. Snuggie on that.
Snuggie snuggie snuck Alicia. Scott is tired.
It's delicious. He does have a leg. My legs get tired.
Oh Shit. What the fuck? Tali roll still tall. It's tight. Damn.
That's talking about boys. Roland goes back, dude.
Is he going to put him to sleep? Oh my God. This is incredible. No, he it.
He lost.
He's still in it. No, I lost it. Nope, he's out.
[inaudible] he pissed Khabib off.
He tried to take a little breather truck after that go.
That Kia team took on his neck. You tugged on the beer snack.
Now he's going to fuck you up. I, his dad right there.
Nothing moves on his face. Makes you think, look of elite Brazilian Jujitsu.
Black belt gets him in a position like that as he's trying to take him down and
he's an elite presented you as a black belt. Hey, no,
but like a dobby ramen style. No, no. You know,
you know who I think has the style to beat could be Tony Tayga.
Brian Ortega or Tony Ferguson, but Brian Ortega as far as his, uh, neck attacks.
But the thing about Tony, oh, here's that fulcrum chart. Oh, this might be it.
Nope. Nope. Tony could beeps the fight all day. I see.
I disagree with Brian RTO cause he's too small. He's 125 pounder. Oh,
he's a huge fan for these 145.8 Ferguson is the man. Oh,
he's under the neck. [inaudible] tap, tap, tap.
Wow. Could beep. He's a goddamn monster. If leap is on stone on Steve now,
dude, Tony could be look at this. Even could be said that though.
Could be big as a god damn monster. What's he doing? Is He hugging his dad?
Where's he running into the crowd for? With the camera go.
Did he go to hug his dad? Yeah. Yeah. Oh, he starts knocking Dana. Oh,
look at that man. That's amazing. He's hugging everybody. Wow.
He's humping through there. I think they're jumping up and down with them.
That's his dad. I think with the white hair we went on, we went out on a limb.
Brian, it made it fun. It made it fun, but he was, he was on my guns.
My money buys 400 you gotta take your money. Look at this 400 for a reason.
Mine, I loaned you a hundred you owe it to me. Pour it. Portray,
made it fun though for a little bit. And that's what you gotta do, man.
That's his dad. So that wasn't his dad that he was jumping around with.
That was somebody else. His daddy guy could be a good fight. Great Guy.
Great Guy. Look at that. Look at that. Beautiful, beautiful sportsmanship.
I think you'd be Gibbs only to do two more. Beautiful.
That's what it sounds like. Two more. He's not interested in the long game. Who?
Ferguson. Then who else? I don't know. He wants GSP.
Just be wants to fight to me. It was just amazing man.
He man saying what a man. That's it. It's totally [inaudible]. That's it. Oh,
that's it. That's the only song. Now here's the difference.
Here's the difference in Mys. Tony Ferguson does not get tired,
never gets tired, doesn't get tired.
It doesn't matter if you take them down and he's just scrambling mother fucker
and he can cut you up with elbow Bose from the ground.
And he's got Darcy's from every everywhere dude. He's got long arm.
He just fucked one little mistake. And you're in a Darson.
It's over with triangles. Darts is g teens,
you name it, he can hit you with his elbows from the back.
And here's the biggest difference is Tony does not get tight.
Tony's one of the only fighters who bombed saying from round one,
he's even better in four. He's the only guy that we know who gets better.
And before you've trained with him, you've been in this camp.
What the fuck does he do to
have that kind of endurance?
He just, he, he is, um, he has,
uh, you know, my son is seven and he like,
he loves baseball and he came at me with some fucking Vince Lombardi quote,
did like some of Michael Jordan Shit.
One day we're walking in basketball practice and, and um,
my son does savage dude and he, and I said, how do you like baseball so far?
He said, Daddy, you know, practice is my favorite sport.
Mike Sh Practice this for practice is my favorite sport.
You can put that on a fucking wall. That's pretty practice is my favorite sport.
My seven year old told me that.
That's an amazing fucking pretty shit. That's brother Jordan Shit.
That's Tony Ferguson. Shit. That's a tee shirt. Tony Ferguson,
he loves training. Did he loves the, what is it?
But what does he do specific? He does that.
You've been in this camp like what is he, what is his schedule like?
Just cardio all day. What kind of cardio?
The traditional shit. And then he makes up shit. Okay.
Starts off in the morning. How's he start off in the morning?
You know what he does? He's, he's, I don't know his exact schedule,
but when you've been there,
what have you give me a typical day like in big bear,
when you guys go to big bear, he's wearing cans, sprinting, uh,
doing all sorts of like, uh, like football, calisthenics type stuff,
drills, like all sorts of shit. Like he's,
he loves training.
That's his secret weapon is he fucking loves it. He wants to train all day.
He does nuts. That's what he's gonna eat. Like, um,
when he's not training for a fight, he eats like anybody else. No,
when he's trying Tacos, Burritos, he don't give a fuck.
He'll blow up to like one 85 when he's training. When he's training,
he's a fucking machine dude. He's a machine. He's just, he eats like
all the best shit. And he trade like when you're eating with him,
what's he eating? I don't eat with them cause I ate some bullshit.
I'll go to in and out. You know what I mean? He ain't going yet.
You'll veer off on your own path. Yeah. And so he's got money, many prepped,
everything's meal prepped. Him and his wife that like he did.
He just, it's like a savage. He's just,
he didn't put the hat on John Anak. He always puts that shit on. No,
he does it to you, man. Respect. Hey, Jamie d, can you hear what he's saying?
Is he calling anybody out? Yeah. Let's give it some volume.
I'm assuming he's going to call Tony out. Let's hear this. Yeah. GSP.
Maybe I can get permission from the UFC to play volume in the background.
That'd be dope. Why not? Come on.
Think it would ruin shit and fuck you for that. That's not that.
It's just so you could hear. They could hear results. Here we go.
He just saying how much respect he has for Dustin.
I have a lot of grades. It's not what I want to hold it. Everything.
We really, what do you want to do?
[inaudible]
respect. Oh
no thanks. What? [inaudible]
people can hear this, but he's, he's saying respect, respect,
teammates, respect gym coaches.
You can leave your Jean ever
keep clean your gym. He's just a class where doesn't show a shirt.
He is wearing Dustin. Pour your fucking scores on. Man. That's beautiful.
That that makes me tear up. He was wearing Dustin's fucking [inaudible].
He's an amazing him and vain is incredible. I'd leave the nice guy in the world.
The guy's amazing. That really is incredible.
[inaudible] 17 oh,
he's got 12 wins just below George Saint Pierre is 13
hold on. [inaudible]
look at these killers behind him. All those dudes. Look at his dad.
Tough fucking [inaudible]. He goes [inaudible] rounds right now.
[inaudible]
he's speaking now in his life. You ever hear him?
When they were asking about the Conor McGregor stuff,
like jumping in the crowd and he goes, I've got gotta. See my dad. He does.
I apologize. My Dad. I got to go home and tell my dad because dad
probably slapped him around.
Well, all my [inaudible] [inaudible]
dude, I'm just talking shit.
There you go. I'm glad when he did, he followed father's plan.
[inaudible] [inaudible] congratulations to you and not be [inaudible].
[inaudible]
wait to get back to the octagon. You did drop the name [inaudible] here,
John, and there it is. Heard it. Here we go.
[inaudible] here we go. [inaudible] go watch. You know, I didn't feel much
[inaudible]
give me a couple of days to think about it. Bad Ass. Yeah. Good for him. John.
Anik does the best post-fight interviews and the game. Very clear cut.
He's the best. So good. So good at it. I don't like doing them.
They should make him do them. I met God. Who the fuck? I mean,
Tony First is the only guy who can really compete this amazing.
A lifetime of discipline. Amazing. Oh, was it Dustin after this here?
This where's Dustin girlfriend here? Um,
I mean it goes right back to the drawing board is a good fight.
[inaudible]
keep it cranking up Jamie. Grant get higher.
I mean, I knew he was going to president.
I was going to be against the pins a lot.
Just want like cut myself down. You know,
I didn't cut any corners here for this.
Oh, come on, Dustin. You all right buddy?
My whole career has set me up for this moment, but
[inaudible] I Bet Sharon, listen,
the respect man. Beautiful Man.
People came from all around the world for that fight. Oh,
he's such a great dude now. I love him.
Oh, now I've got to wait. We good?
But look myself in the mirror every morning with this resolved.
Yeah. He's just dealing with the aftermath year.
I think person he's taught me in the past,
there's more time to good to be grateful and with times like this be graceful.
So I'm gonna just go home. Good for you and my family. It's been a long road.
I'm proud of everything I've accomplished in this sport.
I have a lot of dreadlocks in the tires,
but right now I just need to sit down to date, man.
And there was no hacker, beautiful shirt. His daughters the shit.
All right, let's kill that Jamie. I love this.
This makes me more excited than ever for Tony Ferguson fight because I think
fatigue plays a gigantic factor in any could be fight. And uh,
I think that is one fucking tool that Tony Ferguson has in his box that very few
people have. The kind of endurance of that guy has.
It's almost superhuman Ferguson. Yeah. Almost superhuman. Yeah.
And also he's so good at rolling. Like he don't, he don't just take Tony down.
It's not like you shoot and he resist and then boom, he's on his back.
When you shoot, Tony goes with you transitioning.
He rolls with you when you shoot ramble. [inaudible] yes,
that's the difference. Kimberly train.
He'll throw them at every angle member when he DAARS mark nine 99.9% of fighters
out there don't see Darcy's though, like Tony does.
Tony sees him at every x, the fight, man.
He could be inside control in a fucking room.
The ramen.
And how about the fact that he fucking hit Barboza with that shit when they were
covered in blood and sweat and chaos and coming off of this watching Dustin
almost catch that guillotine. Tony. Tony catch that good.
One of Tony's
strongest weapons is the fact that most fighters,
boxers or MMA fighters or whatever,
they're trainers will tell you the same thing.
[inaudible] the goal is to take their performance in the gym and take it to the
ring. And most people can't do that. Most people fight their best at the gym.
They just can't take it to the the ring.
There's just too much pressure or whatever, or they're just too cautious.
Too much. There's just so much pressure. Tony does not have that problem.
You could. It's any proves that time and time again when you look at like, uh,
that w when he throws like a spinning elbow. Yeah.
He not only does it, will he throw a spinning elbow and not give a fuck,
but I'll throw two in a row. Dude, that tells you right there.
He also improvise. We're told he's a lot like Nate Diaz, like Nate B is,
and like Nick d is what happens when they get in the ring is they don't give a
fuck.
And they actually do perform like the in the ring like they do in the gym.
That's the biggest difference is I remember, I remember Tommy Morrison,
his biggest thing was can we take what he does in the gym and take it to the
ring in front of the world and just, he just couldn't
do it on a consistent basis. And most fighters, that's the big problem.
Can you do what you do under pressure under the whole world?
And Tony has [inaudible] problems with that. That's as big as,
especially when he goes out there and he, dude,
he will improvise on the spot and do shit and throw caution to the winning and
give a fuck. That is why Tony is dangerous because he has no,
once it gets in the ring it's like there's no pressure. What's all season?
The pressure is on you dude,
because I'm going to come after you with everything.
So the pressure is on the other. So he goes out there and he plays,
once Tony starts dancing, it's over dude.
Once he starts dancing and you see Tony just start doing crazy shit,
you're fucked.
Has He ever lost yes to cause the last fought was to uh,
um, John's uncle John Johnson. Michael Johnson.
Cause Michael Johnson broke his arm. He lost the decision, he threw a kick,
he checked the kick and it broke his farm and he was out for like a year.
He had like metal plates in his arm and everything.
So it was Kinda hard to win that fight. But um,
it's going to be a great fight. Tony's one of five.
He's on a ridiculous wind streak and isn't like 17 in a row or 12 here's a
longer WinStreak than could be in the UFC.
But he is the longest win streak besides John Jones. Right.
It's really kind of amazing that he hasn't gotten a legit title shot yet other
than interim. Well he just got hurt, right? Yeah.
And then those could be fights, you know, like can be miss out or,
or you missed weight. It's, it's perfect now.
All that shit in the past built this up.
So now it's better than ever because good is better than ever right now.
So good. He is.
Jesus gets on your back. Nobody can solve that problem.
Well is grappling is just so superior to almost everybody else in the sport.
That's why I think Tony stands a chance because Tony's grappling is so
interesting and he's so agile and the thing he does,
like if you watch Tony Train,
like he's always like moving in weird ways and that's not like for fun.
That's actually how he fights. He moves and he does that for real.
I slices you with elbows,
video that he put on Instagram of him like fucking with the wing Chung dummy and
all these wing Chung experts came out like he's not doing it right. He's, oh,
that's not wing Chung. I don't know what the fuck he's doing. Like, dude,
Tony's doing whatever the fuck he wants. He'll beat you up.
He'll take a whiz chunk dummy and do Tony Ferguson on.
He'll beat your founder up. Oh their show did that when he was fucking up.
Donald Serone. I was lash. Look at him, dude. He's the man.
The other thing you gotta to think about with Tony as you can't watch the train,
fuck this shit. You can't find anyone to mimic Tony.
He'll get you from all angles. Dude.
They'll knock you out and submit you in the same fight.
He's just so on with the bikes. Yeah,
I definitely was having a little success in the early, in the early round,
but he didn't, I mean he mounted them and he got in a good position,
but he didn't do any damage.
There's been some fighters that have had some success, you know, but,
but there's been success on Khabib too.
What you're dealing with the equip fighters, man,
whenever you're dealing with elite fighters,
you're dealing with guys that are gonna test each other. I mean,
of course it's not going to run through everybody.
He's going to have some difficult moments,
but his ability to win is unprecedented. It's right up there.
Tony could beat, ran through everybody. The difference between Tony,
every ball of cubby clip tonight got put into a bad situation.
Just like Tony has been put in a bad situation. [inaudible] got clipped tonight.
But the difference between Tony and all of Khabib's opponents is once generally,
most in the last time, I forget most of the guys that could be takes down,
they're spending all their energy trying to get back up.
They're trying to get back up in the news that they're trying to get back.
They're trying to drag themselves up the fence. Tony's not going to do that.
Tony's going to attack,
embrace Khabib's never dealt with a guy that's gonna actually go,
okay, we're on the ground. Let's do this. Yeah.
So that's going to be the difference. You know what, I'm not, I'm not,
I'm not making predictions or anything.
I know I've been in this sport long enough where I know anything can happen.
You can't predict any fights and promise cookie, no controls on the ground.
Whenever your Jujitsu is, whatever it is,
he can chose your hips and your legs will CLL. Nobody can,
has just takes everything away. Okay. He can, I respect that. Right?
He pins your hips to the ground and just see you later. But he hasn't,
he hasn't fought anybody with Tony's, uh, uh,
weapons on the ground. And the fact that Tony's not going to try to like draw,
spend the whole round trying to get back up.
He might try to get back up here and that spots,
there's going to be spots where it's like, okay, let's attack this.
I'm on the fuck. And it's a different ballgame.
It's a different game when [inaudible] trying to keep the guy on the ground
who's trying to drag himself up the fence and a guy just turns up in squares
with them and goes, okay, let's attack it. It's a whole different game,
so I don't know how it's gonna turn out. I don't know.
I don't know who knows how it's gonna turn out, but I'm not guaranteeing a win.
I'm just saying it is like that have no other fight. There's nothing else.
My feeling is that if Ferguson can be busy enough on the ground,
[inaudible] Connor ranked number three. He hasn't fun so long.
It seems so strange to me. They're worried if they take them out.
Those rankings are so odd. You know? It's like who makes those?
How do they do that?
I know that the pound for pound rankings are made by journalists like
journalists submit their submissions. So are these, yeah, really the ranking.
Yeah, there's a whole,
there's like a number of journalists who submit soul after. Do you,
don't you think that after like a long lengthy layoff,
how long has it been since he fought Connor? Last time he fought it was Vegas.
How long ago would he be? Twice a year and a half. Two years.
[inaudible] a year.
It's been a year. When I go into yoga class and they go,
let's do ohm and everybody is out of key and out of pitch.
I not here, it's hot, right? [inaudible]
dude, I, I do a yoga. I know I don't do,
I do old man Yoga Dude. What's old men yoga? Oh my God,
it's the greatest yoga ever invented. Why?
Cause you don't do shit
because you know what it is.
It's an hour of some stretching to never do at your house.
You would never do it. So the first five minutes did the, you know, we warm up,
we fucking lay there d we just lay there and I'm like passing out.
I'm like Oh shit.
And then after five minutes she'll grab a lek and then you grabbed the other leg
and I love it. I fucking love it.
And you know how you know we cool down the last five minutes.
We fucking just get in a fetal position and just take a nap for five out of
fear. First Time I show this past, my wife says you've hate this, don't you?
Cause I went with my wife and my son, cause you hate this. I know, I'm sorry,
we'll go to someone. I'm like,
what are you talking about this I found my life's passion.
Oh Man. Yoga Dude. Your, your character. The Lazy Dancer.
Do I go to university 10 apps now dude,
I'll take a nap in June. And my wife gets mad at I,
cause she knows that that noise I make when I go, when I go out, like,
like you know when you kinda call the snoring wakes you up, you're like,
well she's like, I'm gonna kill you. You've been at like, I love Yoga.
I love everybody in the class is at least 85 years old.
I swear to God, me and my wife and my son,
we're like the youngest motherfuckers in the hung.
I focus you still roll Jujitsu? Like lie you a phone?
Uh, I am rolling but um, I'm not like,
you know, I'm not rolling. Like, you know,
I'm training for Abu Dhabi or anything like that.
I'm like trying to lose weight. And you said your shoulder trying to stand. Not,
how long has it been since your surgery in your shoulder? Uh, one year. Exactly.
And it's not 100%. It'll never be 100%. What's it at right now? Dude?
Like if you try to under jack this arm and try to put me in the arm,
I'll tap like right here. Stem. So Bro. Yeah,
we need to get stem cells in there. Once last time you roll kiln,
everybody keeps saying I'm ting. Nice way.
It was when cds were fairly widely available. No, I rolled was,
you know what everyone, the thing about stem, I'm sorry cause I'm down with it,
but every fucking three months there's a new dude that comes out and says, oh,
they did their stem cells like this.
We take our stem cells out of fucking pigs better. And then,
and then six months later, oh, they've been taking their stem cells from pigs.
We take our stem cells from fucking,
uh, aborted fetuses in China. And they're like, okay.
And then the another six months, like, oh, they take their fetus,
they're their stem cells from my board to feed us in China.
We take ours from aboard board fetuses from Haiti.
God like when you guys get to master the shit, it's amniotic fluid now I think,
and they take it from a placenta is not fluid.
What's the latest shit in court that use him? Bill Gibson was on your podcast.
Go to Panama. We do have a hold on him cells. Slow downs did stop, stop, stop.
Listen.
Dr Neil Riordan was on my podcast and he had treated Mel Gibson and Malcolm's
Dad.
Dr Neil Riordan runs a clinic in Panama because they can do things in Panama but
they don't allow yet in the United States because they would have to classify it
as a drug. What does that Ford if you go down,
it's a little bit in that range and I sat my mom down there,
I sent Miriam Nakamoto down there to Miriam Nakamoto has got a fucked up knee
and she, she couldn't get it fixed and she was falling apart.
She's just got it done. She's just got it done. Where do you actually know what?
She hasn't gone to find out. I don't think she's got it done yet. This week,
my buddy went to, people were going to, no, he went to Germany, but he did.
Now the people who are going to, he's done all the research.
They that he said that's cutting edge. She's coming to my, showed him
what's cutting edge. So, so the, the umbrella, there's,
it's called renew r e n u. And uh,
you'd have to read how they do it, but they, it's,
it's essentially from Sicilian sections.
They take the placenta and the umbilical cord from that and those cells,
those cells, I guess are,
they can essentially become anything wants to do Joe not promising around.
That's what I'm doing. And I'll tell you, my buddy did it,
shot it and both shoulders, shoulders hurt for seven years. He said, dude,
I'm telling you. He said he got a lot of them done. He said,
I haven't had in two years. My shoulders haven't heard. That's great.
All this is a secondhand thing.
I've had a full length rotator cuff tear disappear. It's gone. Here you go.
I'm shooting my fucking foot. Yeah,
you show your plantar Fascia says it works really well. I'm shooting in my fuck.
You need to go to lifespan medicine in Santa Monica and talked to Dr Ben Rue.
He zoned Santa Monica. He's phenomenal. Listen,
my guy is the best guy on the planet and trust me in the United States for what
you can get done in the United States.
The guy that I go to is as good as any fucking human that's alive.
It's in Santa Monica, California, so you've got to trust me.
I do all the research. Yep. I've talked to all the doctors. I,
I've read books on this shit. I'm,
I'm about as up as you can get without being in the business.
Has anybody gotten stem cells in their dick? Yes.
That would've been greenfield. Said it made his dick bigger.
I would recommend if you're in Vegas, I would rally back into that shit.
I would recommend Dr Rodney McGee. He's got a piece on him. It's not bad.
He doesn't need stem cells. His Dick Finger for his body.
He has a real problem on his dick. He would go hod Kellen,
you need some like physical therapy on your DQ flux. How much? I'm fucking
acupuncture. But for real, if you, Eddie, if you want to talk to Ben Rowe,
he's the guy that did your back with the Regena King.
Your back was too far gone for that and he
told you your back was too far gone because all it does is act as in,
tell me that. What did he tell you? He said it was gonna work.
He wouldn't like it. Well maybe it would've worked if you didn't do Jujitsu.
The problem at hip point. No, he saw, he saw my ex,
my MRI and my l five s one was like this and he,
he still stuck me with that shit. I said it was going to give you some relief.
Did it give you any relief? I don't know. Eddie's not a fan. I'm not even,
I don't even remember at this point. All I know is just like I've had stem cell,
no one getting stem cells when I went to, they still talk about it.
It's in its day in the office cause yeah,
you're apparently you were hitting him with all kinds of crazy conspiracy
theories while you're in there. Fuck. Yeah. That's why I love that.
He thought I was getting stem cell
treatments.
I went in there and I signed a go stem cell and then at the very end they go,
oh, the same stem cell. This is just the weight of it.
Why did you think it was Texas PRP? I'm like, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's not PRP. It's Regenics different. It's different. It's different.
It's way superior to PRP. It's how I fixed my bulging disc in my neck.
I had a real fucking problem with my neck. No fingers. What'd you do with,
what is Regena cane? It's a procedure they invented in Germany.
Koby Bryant went down there and Peyton manning had his neck fixed.
TJ Dillashaw themselves relax. I know they do stem cells there too.
They do bolt in there. I went in there thinking, listen,
this is what I was thinking. Maybe I'm a retard and I probably am,
but I went in there thinking I was getting sick.
I was telling everybody I'm getting swelled because you didn't listen and then
by the time it happened they go, oh no, you're not getting stem cells.
Why didn't you, why the army? Eddie didn't lie to you. You just didn't listen.
If you want to get stem cells, they can, but when it comes to look, I got,
Regina came to my back last week cause I've been having some sciatic nerve
issues.
My ass hurts and the nerve goes down cause I had a little bit of a bulge that's
pushing on it. Did it help? This hurts for other reasons.
[inaudible] so rude. [inaudible] knows about ass Powell. I know about they,
they do everything. They do everything there. But if I had to tell someone,
if someone had a real issue and they wanted to deal with it,
I would say if you have time, go to Panama because they can do things in Panama.
They can't do. Dude,
my mom was about to get a fucking knee replacement real close.
I sent her down there to Panama and for,
I mean she's 73 so for a while it was like, wow, I don't feel anything.
It's still hurts. But then about six months in she's like,
it really seems like it's getting better. Eight months later, no pain. Come on.
Yes. Come on. Yes, she, she's hiking in the Grand Canyon. One mouth. Yes.
I need that shit. She went on vacation to Vegas.
She can walk with no pain in your neck? Yes. They could put it in and day.
My foot in the doctor and I sent my mom down there again. I just,
she just got back. I sent her down there twice. Why Mom?
Does that call snap a lie when she
came back? You know how mean the price is right?
I don't know what the fuck [inaudible].
I sent her down there and I'll send her down there every time she wants to go.
I'll send him down there three fucking times a year or, I mean it's real,
but they're doing intravenous stem cells.
They're doing direct injections and the problem joints.
Anything you have an issue with, it's regenerating tissue.
I need to see a documentary. Okay. There is there. I got papers on it now.
He's got published journals. Man.
I mean I need to see a documentary article that peaks. Okay.
Listen man, if you go down there,
I guarantee you it'll help you for you show. I'm going to start in Santa Monica.
I'm gonna start getting nervous about the thing about your back and here's the
new, don't sit nervous and Panama, the guys from Dallas. No, no shit.
I just taught you. I told Chaz to,
cause the federal government treats it as a drug and the FDA wants all that
money down to trucks. Come on, Bro. Yeah.
Callen you have to go down there if you want to get in a mileage, because it's,
it's, look, it's smaller doses. You can get it done in America,
but you want to get the fucking full Monty.
We're going to go down there to Panama.
I would be happy to go if I have the time, if I don't get to take five days off,
save your life. My body's fine. My Buddy's fine dude.
Slash they had big results from what I've had done in the United States and I'm
telling you what I get done in the United States is not as potent as what
they're doing in Panama.
He's thought about maybe asking them a trip that pedal a hundred percent I'm
talking to my mom about flights. I know we're hours.
This is what we're going to do. It's more than that. [inaudible] we do this.
How bout all of us had a bar fight companion to sponsor all of us and we all go,
they pay for the free and we blow it the fuck up. Listen,
I already blowing them up. I've already blown them up,
which is why he's willing to help. You know,
like a lot of my friends have gone down my companions stem cell and we talked
about how we feel [inaudible] it up.
What I was gonna do with my families.
We were going to go to Panama for three days.
I get the treatment and then we're going to go from there and jet somewhere else
and then have another injury like so.
So let's just say my ankles. I got all my son the morning.
My fucking ankles are so stiff. 100% they get fixed.
[inaudible] right into the joint. You can even get a little botox. Well this,
listen what Ben Greenfield with Ben Greenfield did with the,
with with his Dick. I told you Ben Grifo got shot his dick.
He got his shot through his whole body. He got a shot in every joint.
It was like they put him under, they did his bat. Louise's ankle.
They did his big toes. Cause he fussed up. Yes. Oh yeah.
I mean he was like for a while, I don't know, it's just like holy shit.
His whole body was like out of it. But he said afterwards,
his biological age dropped.
He said he felt significantly better through his entire body.
Like every joint felt better. His energy level went through the roof.
He said he did you see this? You see what made the news today? But they can,
they, they can do a,
they can reverse your biological clock by two and a half years. Human groves,
Ga foreman. I met from [inaudible] commentary,
but here's the thing about metformin. I met, there's a guy,
David Sinclair from Harvard who's coming on my podcast again next week.
He's been on before. And the thing about metformin is when,
when he talked about it,
he was advising it and talking about the benefits of it.
But then when I talked to people like Greenfield and then also Rhonda, Patrick,
they said there's a performance hit though.
Like your physical performance suffers from it form. It's not,
you don't have as much like you, you're not gonna. It's, it's,
you're not gonna feel as good when you train.
You're not gonna feel as good physically, but it lowers your biological age.
It's a tricky one. Like she's not so like, listen man, I,
I put my fucking right hand on the Rhonda Patrick Bible.
She says as thorough a researcher is there is, and you know,
she's a legit scientist and when she does the research on something,
she looks at every fucking angle completely non-biased and she's not sold on
metformin. And there's a lot of other people that agree with her.
They say there's, there's a performance hit apparently,
but Davidson Claire is not exercising. If he does, he's like, yeah,
no fucking elliptical machine. While he watches the news,
he's not doing anything crazy. But if you're an athlete like I know you are.
Damn right. I was about to say, Joe, that's a great shirt. I just noticed that.
That's a great fucking show.
That's an official [inaudible] coming around for a while I was wearing the all
like I'd wear the official ones at the Wayans.
It's a great tired of them taking my shirt off in front of everybody and that's
a great shirt. Yeah, they make dope shirts, man. They're getting guns.
A bunch of dope shirts that Yo over marijuana. My favorites.
I would offer you the stop. [inaudible]
sent me the style pass. I've worn that one. It looks like the Matrix.
It's like different colors.
That cartoon of a Yellow Romero and a mosfet now.
Yeah. Blow that up. I'm seeing [inaudible] glove.
That is so good bro. Polo coast is the only guy to slow down.
Yoel Romero like literally like put it on him where Yo always puts it on
everybody. Yeah. He made EOL fight off his back foot. He made yo l like,
like little like having a hard time setting up to throw shots.
I didn't know Cosa was that good though. He'd be sleeping. You'd be dreaming.
He could. I can't play it. I didn't know Costo was that God damn Downton.
What'd you say? Oh, somebody else's video.
Youtube is holy go. Well it's man,
you guys don't watch football so you can give a fuck. Something happened.
And I know Antonio Brown signed with the Patriots. Is that bad?
Oh Dude.
What is it about the dark side that just added to the best team in the world and
he's the best quarterback? The best coach. Oh,
how is that guy still the best quarterback at his age? 42 stem cells. Is He,
well he's definitely done some of that shit. Ton of it. Yeah.
That doesn't take hits. He takes his credible kind of incredible lines.
He's just getting sense because before him,
remember his drew Bledsoe like drew Bledsoe was awesome.
And to think that drew Bledsoe's back
would be the best mother fucker of all time.
Especially that cause no one ever thought that. Cause he not a fast runner.
He's nice. He's, no one's ever thought that the true blood flow was high level.
Yeah. How about that dude that just retired? What's his name?
What's that guy that retired man, you're Andrew Luck. Yeah. Why did he retire?
Because he,
he's at 29 he had a a hundred million dollars or whatever and he's [inaudible]
graduate engineering or architecture Stanford.
He had other options and he's like, I don't want to get my head. No.
He kept getting hurt though, so he was a baller, super baller,
but he kept hummed. Horrible injuries had missed a whole year.
Previous to that thing, came back, got an NFL player that come back,
play with you. Then just his line suck,
kept getting hit and has money in the bank. Super Smart Kid. It was like, Oh,
I'm out man. I don't have the passion for it.
I looked at the list of cal ski saying things like Brandon who played football,
I go hit a last ready to kidney. He had a lacerated lacerated kidney.
He had a lacerated liver and he looked at the list and I was so horrified.
My job was like, what? Like that's it. Looks like you've been to a car accident.
And Brendan goes, it's not that bad. No, there's guys way,
way worse.
Even Robin Broski was talking to a like a crowd and he started getting emotional
talking about how he kept getting hurt and like his mind was in in it and he was
hating the play.
It's just he guys placed in fucking four man and you play into your twenties and
you're like fuck this man right after was money in the bank.
You also see these guys that are getting pulled around in wheelchairs when
they're in their sixties and they can't remember what their name is.
There's a lot of that tunnel and we are aware of it now where they weren't aware
of it 2030 years ago. I think fighters,
two fathers a lot smarter now like Nate Diaz, like dude,
pay me what I'm worth man.
I know I'm on the reverse side of that is you see a lot of guys like
that have had many concussions in football like Troy Aikman and Steve Young.
They've had tremendous amount of concussions and they're commentating and they
sound like they say to Jean, they say,
did you get knocked out by some gigantic 260 pound guy?
Run a full clip like eight times.
Didn't you get like [inaudible] on off season doing commentator commentating and
they sound brilliant. There's fighters like Elster over him.
Sugar Ray Robinson is a no, no, no secret. Oh,
sugary Robinson. You mean Lennon or Robinson letter? Yeah. Struggling,
struggling, struggling. Go to his Instagram page. And by the way,
Rob Smash struggling. No, no, no. He has a hard time talking.
And then Robinson was struggling real bad late in his life.
Like Steve Young, he's had him in Troy and I've had,
Overeem is the guy that explained there's no, there's,
there's not a hundred like there's an off season.
It's an off season a hundred is an exaggeration joke.
But in football you have an off season. You have a lot to tell you, right?
To say a billion, a billion concussion. No, but seriously,
and those guys are commentating for Fox and CBS and NBC particulars a gene they
can't treat. You can't kill for Lich at all.
When you're commentating for fucking NBC, you can't glitch.
You have to be on by [inaudible] NPO.
[inaudible] something that I've been tested for it. Yeah. Yeah. I don't have it.
Thank God. We'll see. Yeah. I don't see any good tickets now because CTE, CTQ,
kicking, any seconds you say, I see no sign of CTE on the sidewalk. I see him.
Yeah. What you do? What on who? In Brennan? Trenton. You don't see nothing?
Not even a little bit. You see some? No.
Oh God.
Oh fuck. He's going to be another intervention.
That was good dude. What was there that would want to do that? No,
this is people that are fighting currently that do worry me though.
You have conversations with them and they sound like they're drunk. Yeah.
And then they pull it together for fights. Yeah,
they pull it together and they look at it at fights.
But you know what the thing is though, Joe, on the average, I know in the,
in the media, and this isn't a conspiracy,
he might agree with this city and this to your point, believe in
[inaudible] that shit. Well, I'm just saying Bryan. So you see cts everywhere,
cts everywhere in brain trauma, but the odds are you're not going to get it.
There's more guys better off.
Who played in the NFL and college football and fought true fine.
Then those that are stupid. It's actually true. Okay.
The odd odds are most of the are fine for socks.
There's out there that have been like fucking shut off a few times that do not
know about the longterm CT study that they did where they've tested 111 people
in 110 of them had CT yes. That they were, well they were slept 10.
How did they do to, it was a selected 110 minutes. I mean what is it?
There's an ability to like try and keep tasks or something? No, no, no.
They have the ability to determine whether or not yet. That's a very dramatic,
what was that? It, that's a little bit of a trick, uh, based on Taiwan MRI,
those, those, and correct me if I'm wrong, those samples that were,
those samples were donated by their family and those guys showed signs show
signs. So, so that was a, that was kind of not a very good control group.
Their bodies are fucked up. Their joints,
their back 100% but their brain though,
there's more guys that don't have CT than do. That's interesting. Yeah.
Well Ken, Ken, someone be kept alive with just their head. Yes.
Yeah. Is there, is there proof of that? Oh, you mean like a head transplant? No,
no. Like, like I try to like, cause you have, I lost my arm. I'd still be alive.
Right. If I lost both arms, I still be alive. Both legs.
At what point in your heart? I need to live. I need long you,
you need to gotta breathe. You need that Gabriel. Yeah.
You need the holistic medical science has went down a weird road.
What have you had a head and you had like a some blood support.
You had a machine,
you know there's guys that have been knocked out a bunch of times like Oh,
like I said, Overeem, Overeem is one of the best examples.
You talked to that guy, he sounds fucking clear as day.
He's been knocked out by mean gang. Oh, time. He more than anybody in the se.
Yeah, a gang of times and he sounds fine. Super. For now.
It says no problems. Hopefully he, I mean,
and he's still winning and still fighting. Well, it's like,
have you seen that nicotine helps with that? With that the studies are nicotine,
so nicotine, the way it's delivered, fucks people's lungs up, stuff like that.
But nicotine by itself can take you in.
The chew actually helps with brain trumps, stuff like that. It helps us.
Silicide dementia. Siliciden apparently regenerates neurons. Yeah.
It's one of the rare things that regenerates neurons.
Another thing that's supposed to be really good for it is lion's mane,
lion's Mane, mushroom, Paul Stamets,
who's a mycologist and Paul Stanley Stamets. Oh,
different guy close. He's been on my podcast before.
He's coming on again to,
he's a legitimate scientist and next time to possibly see your podcast.
Can you invite me please? Yes. I have a, again,
I don't know if we'll ever be on it yet. Just to one day. Okay.
Please don't apologize to him for when you met him, when your younger kiss,
did you ever hear anything back from Kanye? We'll talk about that off the air.
Not, not bad. Nah. Yeah, it just hit me.
I think it's better for that guy to not do podcasts. Just make great music.
This is why I don't think you can.
This is why I don't think it's gonna work for you.
You're not gonna let him rant like Trump does and get away with all that stuff.
It's not what you do with Trump.
Let's say you never saw that video of him in the White House talking about
making his own like book and Vocabulary Shit and Trump's like, that'd be cool,
dude. Trump's like, okay, you're on my side, right?
I'm talking long as you with me. I'm a Kanye Fan. I'm telling you I am too.
It's amazing.
I think she's incredibly eccentric and I think if you're going to be incredibly
eccentric the way he is,
you're going to have a lot of nutty thoughts and ideas and he also has some
mental health issues like legitimate that he's discussed that are public and
that that I think in some ways may contribute to his art because he's off
medication. He was on medication for awhile and the way he talked about it,
he was saying that it was stifling him. It was fucking him up telling him, yeah,
it was doubling his ability to create, how could it not? It's a fine,
it's a fine line though, right? Because we're making great art. Amazing.
What made him amazing is this wild mind that he has. But this wild mind is not,
it's not based on mathematical truth and logic and reason.
It's based on this ability to just go with the flow and think what you think and
be confident in your decisions and just be,
and this be in touch with your emotions and your feelings.
And I mean he's a fucking incredibly prolific artist and to leave that guy alone
and I think the Kim Kardashians situation's perfect because she loves him.
They have a family together. I bet she kind of keeps him grounded.
Her and her family obviously have an amazing business sense.
So like they'll keep all the money tight, keep everybody together.
I mean she's got fucking more loot than God.
So have Kim Kardashian on your podcast. You know what? I'd have her,
I'd have her come on and talk about her decision to help with prison reform
because I think that's really admirable.
There's a lot of people that have made a lot of money and they've gotten real
famous and they didn't do shit with it. But what she's done, she goes MP free.
Yes, she's actually,
and she's actually pushed a narrative that you can do something like this and
she's talked to Trump, but she's visited the White House and she's got,
I think something like 18 people freed from prison that were wrongly
incarcerated. Pretty close. So respect to her. I don't,
I don't know ever want to make a Kim Kardashian joke for the rest of my life.
Plus it made a bunch of them. But even if I did,
it would feel less special the one before that one before.
But even if I say Shit, that was Bruce man. But if I did, I mean,
I mean it, but I mean, what she's done is like,
she's decided to make a difference. She didn't have to make a difference.
She could just buy diamonds to get her toes done.
She decided to make a difference, you know, so I respect her 100% man.
There's a lot of fucking, there's this people that learn and grow, you know,
would want to sell people short and just write people off and cancel people
because of this or that and turn it into a noun. Yeah.
It's who you are changing. It's not talking about nonsense,
about the difference between you and I. When we were 28 Oh my God.
The more the level of Moronic Energy, oh my God,
we were morrows and what we thought about all the time in our head as we're
together. Oh, let's go get a
[inaudible] pickle. That's high. Let's get Parata. Oh yeah. I had a flat
Parata and human skeleton in my tank. I said to him one time, I go, yeah,
I want to talk, but I want to talk. That's just basically jaws on a leash.
I want a pitbull the head, oh, help you help you say my house. The next.
He's like, I'm here.
Legitly went to a guy who was fighting dogs to get Brian's died.
I didn't want to fight. I just wanting to find,
knock that I wasn't gonna fight it. I just wanted a bad ass tall.
You want the Lowe's a sweet dog?
Did you get the dog was a great friend watch on a farm. Oh,
I'll tell you how to tie it. Good question. I had my friend watched on the farm.
My friend calls me and goes, hey, your dog's not with us anymore. I go, why?
He goes, yeah, sorry about that. Wow. Lab News. I shot it. And I go, oh.
And he goes, yeah,
so you could have told me that that dog was going to turn on at any minute.
And I go, the dog went after a baby calf,
a cow. I was holding on to it. The neighbor's dog. Well, no, I'm sorry.
Let me start again. It killed a couple goats.
Then when after the baby calf and when the, the family dog came out,
which was like a German shepherd, golden retriever. Pippa was like, yeah,
and killed. Got It. Yeah. And broke. It broke its leg.
And then that was when my friend, he said, when I tried to pull that dog off,
it was so swollen. It was like, it was like the small dog. It was,
it was pulsing and it was covered in blood and it was so excited and I was like,
I was like, oh, this is a demon dog. And he shot the dog. Wow.
Because he was like, I can't have this talk on my phone. He's got a gun.
He's a farmer. He's like, everyone been fucked. Yeah.
Well they don't bite people. I know. He was as hell on four wheels.
I know a dude who had wolf dogs. They were like seven,
eight Timberwolf and they got out of his yard or he let him out. I don't know.
But they went to a neighbor's farm and killed like eight sheep.
They'd come back just bathed and blood will just come from blood wolf dogs.
They are illegal in a lot of parts that they should be at all, man.
Like cit. Fuck you. Yeah. And was like the conversation you have with the dogs.
See it? Yup. Fuck you. They're big. They're big man. Big Dr.
Pack instinct is very, very strong.
So children are lower on that totem pole than they are.
And so what happens is they look at children as below them subservient.
They don't look at him as part of the family cause they're, they haven't,
they're very pack oriented, the bite kids and that. So they'll take kids out.
Did you hear about that guy that got attacked in British Columbia while he was
sleeping in his bag? You sleeping in a sleeping bag?
I'm going to get a lot of mail. Me To 10 tried to drag him out, attempt.
People were screaming wolf bit him was dragging him.
The Wolf's ass was hanging out of the tent, pulling this guy out.
The guy's screaming,
the wolves got ahold of his arm and then some other people kicked it,
some other campers woke up, kicked it, threw rocks at it.
Gray wolves almost never do that. But that, that was what they have in the past.
You know, there's a story on happen. Well, they kicked in,
the thing ran off and they threw rocks at it.
And then the forest rangers got shot at and yeah,
I'm going to get a shit load of emails from people who own wolf dogs.
Don't send them to me. I don't want to hear it. I'm sure they're great.
Dogs are great dogs. Just you've got to be in control of it.
There's a guy in my neighborhood that does one.
You gotta be in control of that God damn thing. You gotta in the kids.
They're great dogs. They [inaudible] around. Yeah.
But a key is keeping Akita Akita is more of a control.
Ikea's WIC where you buy cheap furniture, but a Akita, Akita, Akita, Akita,
you said, you know what they said? Kia [inaudible] car,
Akita, Akita
[inaudible]. Apparently it's a Japanese bear hunting dog.
They said that the curly tails dogs [inaudible] aggressive, quiet.
They're very quiet.
They pretend to be good for people that have allergies cause they can be
hypoallergenic. They, they are. Um, uh,
and they are pretty good watch dogs, but they're very dog aggressive, you know,
very dog.
One of their main characteristics are that my landlord had one is that they're
only loyal to their master and they don't give a fuck about anybody else.
You know, most dogs are all about love. You know, most dogs,
like all they care about is love. They just want love, love, love. Yup.
Not Akita. They didn't want that.
All they want is food from their master and everyone else can suck this trip,
dude, I, I lived around a motherfucker like that and I was scared.
I was scared as shit. There's bad ass dogs. He's all Dick too.
He'll go right after our mail at all.
Last thing Kito wants is love that aren't really, they don't want pets.
That's one dog talking about a really low fucking control group. No,
that's why they're Japanese police dogs is because of their Co.
That quality is that they only care about their master and everyone else,
all the, they won't bite everyone else.
They just don't give a fuck about no one else. They're like,
please stay away from those. That's like this German Sherri. I lived with one.
My landlord had gone guard dogs. He wanted guard dog. He
was a meth dealer. Oh Jesus. My landlord. Your landlord was a meth dealer.
Oh my God. So you mom, you wanted Akita,
you got to pay the guy the rent and he's fucking, no, he was called to me.
EMS was involved in a lot of shady shit and he had that dog for a reason.
Like that was some serious protection like navy seals and shit.
This motherfucker you, whenever I came around I was scared of Shit.
I'd come around the house and I was like, I'm paying the rent and that dogs,
I please don't pet me. Bite your fucking arm.
If you pet the [inaudible] stereo, who's just like, but shepherds,
shepherds, they're like a good German shepherd and Belgium Elmore's those dogs,
they're a lot. They, they bond on one person, but good luck if it,
those dogs are trained,
those big mail check line showers that my buddy Ryan has enjoy that shit like a
my buddy Ryan who he, yeah, he's trying my dogs, right?
Ryan can take his dog in the middle wallets biting asleep while it's in the down
position, waiting for the command. You can go up and pet it.
He can say go get him and he'll go to your house.
He will not touch a woman or a child. But if it's a man and you're in the house,
he get up take and there's no barking.
He's taken each shepard talk dude, just coordinate. You touch his body.
I'm just playing ball walk. He's always 10 minutes. Did I send you to his dogs?
Dogs amazes dogs. Amazing Shepherd.
He's really good at getting real great talks cause he goes for temperament
first. So the dogs will come out and he goes to Connecticut this one place,
he'll get these fucking dogs and I've met probably six of them there.
They're fucking terrifying. They're already grown dogs.
They're already fully trained, but you can pet them.
They're fucking really friendly up doing.
Meanwhile they're really well taken care of and they're trained right.
They're worked out well. So his dog, that's big for those dogs.
They have to exercise. What do you will have?
One of his dogs was there with me and it was fully trained and the gardeners
that he had never seen. We're just there.
And the dog didn't bark a go after him and all. And I went, but the dogs,
those guys didn't even know those guys and my, and he goes,
why they're not acting in a threatening way because just haven't deployed them
on them. I'm gonna go get some tea. Do you do,
I don't know if you remember a sketch that got rejected by the man show that's
got super pets that we wrote that it was about,
it was about like if your sister, you're suspecting that your,
your kids are doing drugs.
Like you get a family pet but it's actually a uh,
drug sniffing dog that you bring into your family.
And like the commercial was like, you have to like,
your kids think you have like this,
you brought home a dog but it's a drug sniff in college. And if you,
if you're doing drugs like the background with like the doll just tearing apart
your kids and you're all happy because it found the drugs that's super pets.
I liked that. Rejected it, got rejected. Whatever.
The ones that we would never be able to do today,
but we couldn't even do it back then. That's first Asian NASCAR.
Bobby Lee as a car driver just constantly crashing into walls.
He's a superstar. Cars get NASCAR, drivers lying into the Christian NASCAR,
he would keep crashing and everyone loves the crafts. Racist
Asian NASCAR. How about sac fighting?
Ultimate Stack fighting championship that got green lit and then got cut off
halfway. It was all about kicking people in the balls.
Like that's the balls were exposed out of your body and when the balls are in
play, what? What was the balls are in play? The game changes.
So you gotta have like no shorts but you got to have an openness.
Your ball stung up. Yeah. Target. If the balls are in play,
like you don't keep your hands up, you keep your hands down, you want the god,
you in the face. You want to protect your balls. So it was,
we had this whole sketch where like, it's called extreme sack fighting.
Joey Diaz was going to be the master because he had the biggest stack and like,
you know, Joey Diaz, his balls would hang down low and he was like,
he was the guy like the big boss at the end of a video game. How would,
how would fight him change in the UFC if you didn't wear a cup and,
and you could kick in the balls fighting. That's what we did actually.
They did pride. Right. Baseball. You, you'll see one.
You'll see two though and be like,
remember when big daddy Goodrich grabbed the Pedro's Dick and balls? No.
Crushed him. No. [inaudible] controlling the guys. There was a scene,
there were no dairy.
Goodrich grabbed his dick and balls and was crow inside his handful. Yeah.
Crushing about the scene.
I've got a scene where a guy in between rounds and it's,
Paul's are all all like popping out and their cut and there's dudes like,
uh, and swell on your palsy. Like just code them.
Just cut 'em and get Paul's and everyone's trying to do balls
like rocky. We're cutting Mickey cooking when fucked by the way.
No one's ever done. No one's ever cut anybody.
That was a dumb scene and rocky cut me blossom though.
Like why are we cutting for my son, for my son? I sat him down.
We went through rocky one, two, three,
four all dig in like two weeks movies. You got to go back and like, dude,
those movies were fucking great. Great Dude.
Those are fucking two great movies. Are you kidding? Rocky five,
forget about that. But rocky one, two, three and four. Are you kidding? One,
two, amazing movies. Amazing Dude.
You went through like real shit. Like rocky won.
He's like the broke doodoo almost one and then rocky two he's like,
he's got money, but then he runs out of money. She goes, man.
Then he has to fight. He has the take the rematch.
So he takes the remap now hockey three he has all this money and he's huge.
And then clubber Lang,
the young guy comes through and he's all hungry and then he gets fucked up.
Dude.
Rocky three fucked me up because clubber Lang beat him like at like at an
[inaudible] or two or three, three an
hour and 15 minutes.
Clubber Lang beats rocky and that you kind of thinking like what?
How does rocky lose? Like what's going on? What happened? And then you realize,
oh shit, they're going to do a rematch in the same movie.
They're gonna do a rematch in the moon because they did it so that if you didn't
think that was going to be a rematch, you're like, rocky loses.
The Russian is too. No for Russians, for me to go back. Tommy Marcy,
you're confused if you're two as you talked about it. Oh listen,
you gotta go back with your kids and watch rock and rock. Two, three and four.
[inaudible] trust. Fuck, I'm fire with fire. My son must go deep.
If my son was so creeping in with Adrian goes, when Adrian goes to rocky,
when he was going to fight cleverly, she goes, you can't win rocky.
And I thought, oh my God, my son's going to be like,
cause he was all about rocky was suck. Like he was like,
dad is rocky going to win his rock?
He wants to know though the results now you gotta tell me he's rocky gonna win
now. And then when you heard there's, you can't win rocky.
I looked at my son and I thought he was gonna be depressed.
He started fucking laughing hysterically. He's like,
well what's going on here? I thought I thought he was like so into rocky,
but he was laughing at Adrian saying you can't win Ron.
Cause he knew that rocky could win. I don't know. It was just so weird.
He just started laughing and I thought well what is going on?
Has anyone seen the new ones? Like Apollo creed? I saw creed Z. Good.
Well it's cause he's not funding more cause he was coming up to like number six,
right.
So much wasn't he fighting and six including fight fucking Antonio Tarver Oh my
God, Jesus. I already got knocked down and training for that. Like that.
They were sparring,
like going through the things and like having like little light sparring and
Taryn k Odom, I know Michael B. Jordan got knocked out. Joe, he training.
See the video of it. It was what? The training was actually a filming a shot.
He was supposed to rotate his head, get punched, rotate his head,
and the guy clipped him. Right.
How bout last part five that's coming out. That is so ridiculous.
I was driving by the other day, I look up at the billboard.
You got a geriatric man holding a Bowie knife. Right?
You know what I'm going to give you got to give some bucks to slung credit
because basically he was like written off by Hollywood. Yeah.
Nobody would give him a shot anyway. And he said, you know what,
I'm gonna do expendables and bring all these has been actors kind of like on
paper and bring them together and we're going to have so many of them that we're
going to have a fucking new franchise. He did it. So buster Stallone,
he Hollywood didn't want him deep into
fucking addiction stocks. He brought every morning he, John Vlog, he called bed.
Bam. His daughter's Rep talked brown grid. Everybody Buddy,
buddy back. I met his daughters the other day. They're a lovely,
classy young ladies. Ready to fucking tall
and just great gals, just like I was like,
I'm not talking to girls from Jersey here
and now he's doing fucking first blood again.
[inaudible] first blood, baddest mother fucker in Hollywood. Ever. Dude.
[inaudible] world. Who is better than him? Rocky,
the Rambo's expendables come up who's definitely demolition,
but here's this [inaudible] alone. It's done. But here's what, here's this.
Go from rocky one,
which is 1970 something to Rambo 99,
whatever the fuck we're on in 2019 the mixing boards dudes,
he's on grill board. He's been relevant for, it's still relevant.
The rest just alone is fucking genius, Dude.
I don't know how he's doing about nighthawks nighthawks.
Do remember that was with the you and I would remember it. Uh,
he played a fucking cop with a, who is the guy who was the hitter?
The the off fuck. I don't want to remember rocky three. Fuck.
Who was as all sad? [inaudible] do you ever see the,
they escape with him in Arnold Schwarzenegger in the prison? Yes.
That was like three years ago. Yeah. Classic. So many fucking blockbuster.
Matanzas daddy lambs. He loves B guys. I gotta get Outta here.
Get this bitch up. Let's wrap it up. Can I give a couple plugs for sure. Hey,
next Friday I'm going to be at San Francisco at Cobbs and then the Friday after
that Austin state side theater with me and Sam triply.
We're doing Tim for hot comedy next Friday, San Francisco pride after that.
Austin, I'm in Houston 20th 21st of this month, and then comedy works. Denver,
Tampa Improv. This the 27th of September and 20th of September comes in.
Bye everybody.
We love you.
[inaudible].